what's up people
it's monday
h3 podcast begins now
monday let's turn it up oh dan you got
your tat you got your uh well a b is in
here so i figured i gotta be like kind
of like you gotta be the tatted bad boy
yeah the bad boy the podcast today let
me see those sleeves
what's up rocking the head
[Music]
i don't know who ed harvey is
but what did i wear that for the vin
diesel
i think halloween all right no it was
part of my um face blanks costume
oh that was the blank blanks got it
well guys welcome it's h3 podcast it is
uh
may
my dudes
may 9th to be specific even though the
document says august but i know better
than that
it said eight nine
uh
guys i want to give a special shout out
to our lovely sponsor hello fresh
real quick at the top of the show look
at this beautiful food spring has sprung
and the less time you spend in the
kitchen the better that's why some of
hello fresh is delicious restaurant
quality meals come together in just 20
minutes
get 16 free meals plus three gifts with
code h3tv 16 at hellofresh.com
h3tv16 dang that food looks scrumptious
love you oh and of course
the infamous burrito oh that's hot yeah
abe and lena are out in florida getting
ready for the fight this saturday it's
happening it's all happening
uh so you know
what should we do to watch that should
we all get together or something on
saturday i think it would be fun just
this is just a suggestion but you do
a little stream
with all of us we get together
we can't show it but we can like have
us react we should do a saturday stream
where we just watch something they can't
watch with us that just seems all people
should watch it themselves but you can
have our commentary slash reaction
alongside with it i mean people do that
for big events
right but then you can't watch it unless
you drop 20 bucks
well or you can't enjoy i don't know
what do you guys think i mean i'm sure
people will say yes because they just
want to watch it but
they're saying yes all yes all caps yes
do it really i'd watch it yes yes like
joe rogan fight companions
right yeah our first ever fight
companion guys this is the beginning of
a new era hell yes
it would be fun man i i i'll tell you
what i'll tell you it would be fun to
get sued by idubbbz though
for showing it just go for it you know
go for the the trifecta
you know speaking of claims i got to
give a special
uh screw you
to samantha b
although i'm sure she had nothing to do
with this personally but
you know our last episode
we showed tucker carlson's
the trailer for his uh the the death of
man or whatever
yes on the last leftovers right yeah
with with uh dudes tanning their balls
to include and
increase testosterone
and the whole podcast got claimed but
not by tucker
no
this one this this like 40 second clip
in this two hour podcast
the whole podcast got claimed by
samantha b
you do not even own that footage
not even a little bit
see that's what i'm saying i i maybe i
should talk to our lawyer about this
because this kind of this kind of like
nonsense i should i should have sent
this to our lawyers this kind of
nonsense is just uh
it
it can't go unpunished it can't yeah i
mean it's um
she doesn't her content doesn't even
appear she had the galls to enter
tucker's clip into automated id
that's got to be a crime that needs to
be punished yeah
so shut up tucker actually for not
claiming us
and a giant middle finger to samantha b
you know by the way and did they even
respond to our dispute
uh let me see if there was an actual
because if they actually like we're like
no we own this then then we got war
but then on the other hand if they don't
respond it's also like fu like it takes
two seconds to review this and be like
no that's a that's an error it is
still in escrow so they have not
responded yet
so embarrassing
this this whole
this whole vertical of youtube
media is just
you know youtube has gone
great lengths to make it better for the
creators
the biggest stool is that you can snip
stuff out now
and the copyright goes away
before people were claiming you just had
to
let them take your money forever so
youtube has done a good job of
of protecting
uh
creators
[Music]
and usually i'll just clip it out
because it's not worth you know
because disputing it takes way way way
longer yeah
but with this one i said i'm not i'm not
cutting that
this needs to be they need to know what
they're doing who wants to lose some
money today i don't actually but uh
that's what samantha b says when she
goes to uh browse
tucker carlson footage apparently
have we ever found the source for that
tai lopez thing because i absolutely
love that sound by it
it was from some clip i i think dan
might have sent it to god it's so good
like what's the context of tai lopez
saying that i'm sure one of them i have
to know crypto who wants to lose some
money today
who wants me to take their money
yes ty speak the truth my man let's not
talk about making money
yeah the stock market is just absolutely
getting trash
kind of crazy if you go year to date
what are we down here
um
i'm of course the master investor i put
like my life savings in
the stock market
after it dropped a little bit
it's don't freaking heck dude
it's down 17
since the beginning of the year big
massive dumps you know i'm down like
i'm such an idiot i was sitting on cash
for so long
being like it's gonna come it's gonna
crash this is like unsustainable this is
insane the way the stock market's going
up
and then it dropped like a few points i
said i'm all in
and now i'm down like 15 of my life
savings so shout outs
but it's okay obviously
you're a young man just yeah i just hold
i'm not i'm not stressed about it i'm
just more like
wow you're the worst trader ever
worst timing every time
well now's a good time to buy if you
guys are have some money on hand a
little bit even like a few hundred bucks
i would uh pick up some some stock
now's the time my friend you you're
almost guaranteed i mean right you are
you disagreeing
maybe don't take advantage financial
advice from ethan who just got finished
explaining to all of you how he has the
word if i if i would love to have had
that money to invest it now i mean it's
down seventy percent it's going to go up
again eventually at some point by the
way it's just
what is it
about
tucker b yeah we didn't realize that she
was well within her right that's her
alter ego actually tucker b ladies and
gentlemen
beautiful lady by the way first she's
actually gorgeous i didn't realize how
pretty she is
call the police immediately i'm i'm
actually about to act up on this man to
be all right let me close
giving me dirty thoughts over here
yeah
um
had a
a lot of stuff going on we have actually
a really fun episode of i don't know if
you guys know about the
birds aren't real activists
[Music]
it's a like i would say
a pseudo conspiracy theory it's not a
it's a fake conspiracy theory that
people made to satirize all the
ridiculous conspiracy theories
and the mastermind behind the birds
aren't real
uh conspiracy theory really interesting
young man is going to be calling in at
two fascinated by a story you know i saw
him in like 60 minutes or something yeah
when we were putting together the
research sam was showing me all the
he was on howard the other day oh he was
oh wow so i saw him on 60 minutes and i
was like this kid's this kid's pretty
cool you know
he's real interesting so i thought hey
let's see if he wants to call in and
love your uncle uh he's real interesting
guy actually
he was on howard did i miss that zach
yeah i must have missed it too because
when we were looking into it i i it was
a clip and he was on he called in
oh that's really interesting yeah
but i love what he's doing you know
birds aren't real
he's saying it's a conspiracy but
actually some people are actually
getting it's really interesting how this
works right he starts his conspiracy
burns out real and i'm pretty sure
there's people that actually believe
birds aren't real now oh 100
yeah i mean it's a numbers game like
lots of people heard of it and there's
always going to be that fringe that's
like
you know what well when i
first heard about the conspiracy
i wasn't sure if it was
i didn't know anything about so i was
like okay well that's pretty much on par
with flatter
right yeah i don't see anything hot
earth is old news by the way
uh i was recently introduced in the
concept of the crater earth
okay go on so the earth isn't flat it is
a globe but the world that we know
as our world is simply all contained
within a giant basin like imagine like a
giant meteor crater okay the size of the
whole planet so it it's as if it's flat
to us but there's impossibly high
mountains of this giant crater
uh that are blocking us from reaching
the rest of the world yeah so there's a
whole world out there to explore that's
kind of exciting yeah and and the people
that believe this are serious um but i i
kind of like that they've one-upped
the flat earthers it's like oh you flat
earth that's cute so how do you explain
these huge cliff sides at the end of the
that's a great question i'll have to do
something for them
maybe the crater's just so so so big
yeah there's um
let me see if i can find a diagram of
what yeah
let's dig deeper into greater earth
we have to keep up to date with all the
social happenings by the blood of the
lamb by the blood of the lamb i don't
know if this is
by the blood of the lamb we are in
crater earth
that's spiritual
well okay dan you work on that and let
us know if you uh okay i'll do some
reasons yeah if you if you find anything
you have some more gaga conspiracy
theory stuff later in the show too so oh
the joe biden one
joe biden's on the astral plane now dude
he's on the astral plane i was on the
astral plane once in college yeah i mean
i've been it was a long night last like
15 hours he's smoking up
salvia
i'm taking you straight to the asphalt
yeah no it was it was a long night man
but i'm you know i was glad when it was
over yeah
i was gonna put him in a foot
so anyway um
what else is popping today
um
coming off the bobby lee interview i
don't know if you guys saw that that was
a pretty big interview we had
with bobby lee and kalila
on friday
had long reaching kind of implications
about brendan schaab which i didn't know
much about this guy
other than a lot of people didn't like
him
well thanks to all the posts on our
subreddit i know a lot about them now
but
basically if you guys haven't seen it
our good friend bobby lee said that this
guy bobby schaub
you know brendan brennan oh brent didn't
i like to call him bret brent i like to
call him brendan schwab
just sounds dumber he doesn't deserve to
be a shob
you know
um
bad mma fighter worst comedian
although some people debate what she's
worse at
because apparently he wasn't a very good
fighter although at least he's
definitely worse comedian yeah that's
what i was gonna say he was trained as a
fighter at least
and from what i you know
he was middle of the road like he has
some wins it's not like he yeah he had a
winning record actually like 10 and five
yeah so so obviously uh the interesting
thing about ben brendan
schaub
if that is your real name
is he's the most appeared guest
on joe rogan which basically is the only
reason he has a career like over 70
times i think you told me right cam
i think he said like 86 or something 86
is that right kim that gets my dick card
that's
you didn't tell me that no oh somebody
told me that somebody did account the
other well anyway it's like 10 of all
the episodes he's done so joe rogan's
been building this meat head up
gave him a career but apparently a lot
of people don't like him
because he's an [ __ ] and he's not
funny
um
i don't like him because he's an [ __ ]
but yeah so he was threatening bobby lee
on the phone
because kalila his girlfriend had said
that
years ago when when bobby and her were
together still they've been together for
a few years
that brendan
was hitting on her
and then one a few and then a few other
of the girls that kalila has a podcast
with said the same thing
specifically one of the girls said that
she was trying to get her to come out to
his truck to give her to give him a
blowy
nice proposition right
you want to come to my car and suck my
car wait whoa that's exactly what he's
dead oh where's what's that sound by
from am i brendan schwab do you want to
come into my car and suck my car wait
was i not talking about him that was
that was that was awesome
okay that was a voice note that you sent
me a few nights ago
that's how i you know i wasn't very
successful in the dating world because
that was kind of how where things began
but
elo was the first person that where i
tried a different approach and it really
worked out for me there you go
brendan schaub has 84 appearances my god
yeah it was abey who
came up with that
and so
bobby said that
brendan and another podcaster
or podcasters he wasn't specific about i
don't want to
uh
i don't want to guess
who
out of respect for bobby but called and
threatened his career said they were
going to tattle to joe rogan
they said he's a [ __ ] he's always been
a [ __ ] she basically bullied him
and apparently this guy is like an
unhinged alcoholic too so he's kind of
like not wanting to have beef with him
like cobra tate light maybe
covertrate's way worse yeah yeah i said
light
as far as i know there's no sex
trafficking accusations or anything that
right yeah that's pretty no no
no
but uh i just wanted to show my support
for bobby and just say
that i'm really proud that he actually
came out i would say that the net i'm
really happy he came out and just told
the truth about that because it seems to
me
the reception of the episode and maybe
you guys have seen
something but the reception is
overwhelming support for bobby which i'm
really happy oh yeah
everywhere everywhere i've been seeing
that yeah it's really good that he
that he um he talked about it
you know
so shout out bobby
it was somewhat of an explosive episode
and i'm just really
proud and happy of how how open and and
uh
i want to say how brave bobby was and
and talking about all this stuff
because he was really anxious and scared
to kind of
go in about it and they were like trying
to blackmail them they're like we're
going to release dirt on you
you know they had to open bobby opened
up how they had an open relationship for
a minute where collido was seeing
someone else with bobby's blessings of
course an open relationship that's what
it is and these guys thought it was like
some big dirt and they're like we're
going to expose you we're going to put
this out there
so they just came out and said it
but actually when i started looking more
into brendan i there's like a whole hub
of like brendan haye it's real
interesting his show's called the
fighter and the kid
or he has a podcast with his
comedy buddy brian callan
and if you go on their subreddit
it's literally just dedicated to hating
them not unlike our subreddit actually
not to the same degree
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding
just kidding of course
just saying our subreddit is pretty
interesting though everyone sees
photoshopping me i was like a tiny [ __ ]
a tiny little
man lift with tiny hands there's a few
of those in the dark uh
the next link actually
where's the ones everyone's been posting
like i can't wait for the fight with me
like tiny hands where are they
um here you
3000 points thanks guys
at least my hands look big in this
because they didn't shriek my arms well
they look to scale
right you know my hands are big
thank you guys actually that's
that's really nice
let's get hyped for abey's fight
everybody it's on saturday
damn look at my hands they're massive
bro what the hell
i actually look skinny too with like
tiny legs you're like all doors i kind
of like it actually i kind of big ed
style well you you like that uh that
meme guy the
[ __ ] the trumpet dude dan what's his
name
oh
you don't know anything about art you
don't know [ __ ] does anyone think i look
better like this kind of
i'm vibing on it i look skinny with big
hands i'm in
[Laughter]
i look good as hell
someone like cobra tate who's been
making videos about me by the way he
posted a video on his channel like he's
like going to war with me
he'll see a picture like this and think
it's real
but anyway
oh thank you love
he found what we were talking about this
guy he's so funny oh yeah yeah you got
the same energy as this guy who the hell
do you think you are
you any kind of artist
anybody know who you are maybe everybody
else stop it stop it this is
someone's going to claim this okay
g4 viral videos yeah i was like
someone's got a viral hog is gonna come
[ __ ] steal my whole revenue for the
whole
three hour episode cause this little
this little manlet
okay but anyway yeah i started going
through here and i was like whoa this is
crazy i just got real interested in
the whole
mythos of brendan shaw being a piece of
[ __ ]
apparently he's like threatened to sue
other youtubers he does copyright claims
like literally everything i hate
about people and he's just like a big
meat head bully
so it's been kind of interesting just to
see
um
just to learn about this guy
yeah he he here there was i guess
critical made a whole video about how he
was suing another youtuber for making
fun of him
which you know is uh one of my triggers
right right definitely
i'm actually not super familiar with
that but critical's video about it got a
lot of views
yeah so i don't know i just want to
basically share my
support for bobby and just say that uh
brendan is a uh
ground beef brained
alpha bully oh here you go here's
criticals video about it
3.2 million views horrible comedian
sue's a youtuber over jokes yeah
so shout out brendan shop
people it's funny people have been
predicting he's going to come after me
and so i was like he's going to call me
fat
and he's going to uh well he's
definitely called me fat you say you're
not funny
sure that's granted
and what was there something else they
said that was like super on point um
i mean fat i guess fat is kind of just
the it's
just the one that gets every time yeah
this dude's fat what does he even have
an opinion about anything don't you know
if you're fat you just need to not think
about [ __ ]
yeah but
fat ugly and stupid
okay well let's see you side by side
well here's a boxing match i'd take
that'd be an interesting fight people
everyone's trying to fight challenge me
to a fight keemstar everyone a lot of
people want a piece of the action
now this is an interesting fight or
maybe against bagel boss can we get
bagel boss in there next to the bagel
boss yeah the guy who had the panic
attack and bagel boss yeah no i remember
get him in there and let's see
yeah that guy
maybe it's maybe a free-for-all between
three of us oh it's almost like in that
picture you're like the inverse because
he's all legs and no torso and you're
all torso
i actually think i look good
let's get bagel boss in there yeah
photoshop him in there please
now this is this i'm getting ready i'm
training for the next creator clash
[Music]
ethan klein versus bagel boss and torso
uh musicating for all the bagels
he was supposed to fight in a boxing
match but he like
dipped out do you remember that yeah i
do remember i think he was fighting like
a normal sized person though and there
he was just gonna get creamed i think he
just he just oh yes one more addition
this is one of my favorite photoshops
ever
oh it's not about it let's get keemstar
in there oh yeah right that's not a
photoshop
right so here is the ultimate
wait somebody said throw down rip bagel
boss he didn't die did he bagel boss
ate his last bagel are they just saying
because he's gonna get killed in the uh
no bagel boss couldn't have died wait
i think he might have wait how would
bagel boss die he was young and healthy
he had his whole life ahead of him
this might maybe this is just a meme
thank you for the sad music yeah no this
maybe it's just a meme i don't know wait
what are you reading chris morgan the
bagel boss guy dead of 50.
oh my god
according to his manager he had a stroke
his manager this man has a manager
of course dude he's a he's a big rip to
the baseball he had a stroke
too much cream cheese probably
too angry no i'm serious that that's
really high saturated fat you know that
you get that in the arteries man that'll
that'll cut off the oxygen to the brain
real fast
he died
chris morgan the bagel boss guy dead
this is from march 6 2022. oh my god
but maybe it's just a hoax i don't
know that sounds real
real is a stroke or heart attack my
friend
right bagel boss
so i guess you're fighting trumpet man
yeah it's the justice league maybe that
means i won my first fight already
against bagel boss by default
yeah
oh you have a perfect record
i have a perfect record
[Music]
so
alrighty well rest in peace bagel guy
resting cream cheese
just these two now
yeah oh
i'm seeing
oh the rumors of his death are false the
bagel boss lives
thanks
bring the picture of the three of us
back up okay back
yeah he was too he that man that man is
too much energy he's too lively
[Music]
no nothing will ever take him down
[Music]
this is what we were working with
up and up before we found out he was
still alive
so babel got boss is down keemstar looks
to be
i feel like i could kick i would kick
game start real far
this is interesting though
[Music]
can we get willow in there
[Music]
uh he's pretty old now
right but he has magic as well and he's
not just like a short king he he yeah
he's actually a little person yeah he's
a small he's a dwarf i think yeah
so that wouldn't be appropriate to put
him in there
he's also kind of a badass though i
think he would probably [ __ ] you up he's
a baddie that's what i'm saying he's the
final boss
he's the top of the enter the dragon
layer
all right enough oh no
oh well i guess there's a little out cam
must have made this when we still
thought the bagel i i was just looking
at it it was just on the screen
okay sorry can't keep up with these
photoshops too quick
so anyway um
let's see so let's just talk about
yeah what'd you guys think of the bobby
lee though do you guys know anything
about this brendan schaub character
i'm just curious like i said i know a
lot more after this weekend yeah
post about him i mean i was familiar
with him because i had seen him on rogan
many times uh you know years ago when i
occasionally watched his podcast uh can
you pull up that there's this pump sorry
off i just want to search for this
there's a clip of him agreeing with
everything rogan says that oh yeah so
funny sorry to cut you off if you want
to finish your thought though no just
that i was pretty much done brandon
schwab agreeing with joe rogan yeah that
man is dumb as hell man and i mean that
like with peace and love
to [ __ ] kill the [ __ ] out of people
oh tongue a chip on your shoulder and a
thick skin dude the biggest chip on your
shoulders you also see the drawbacks you
see a huge jump
tough to deal with but it's the toughest
to deal with got a dicey pass in terms
of the law some would say the dice
reason for why the roughest oh who knows
it's fun it's so it's the funnest yeah
it is it's the best you feel like this
is a dirty business like i don't want to
be a part of your
dirtiest business
this is a disaster it's such a it's the
biggest disaster yeah it's a good move
it's the best
echo watch 10 minutes of that up next
bob
i love that so much
it is kind of interesting that joe has
this guy on more than anyone who just
goes who just like co-signs everything
he says it's just his echo
it's the dicest yeah
if i want a brendan shop content court
that would be fun but
i don't know that would be fun
it's it's such
i mean not that i was familiar with all
of it but it seems to be very uh covered
ground let's say
right well
well covered ground yeah very much out
there yeah
that's true
someone says my favorite joe rogan uh is
telling him he needs to quit fighting
because he sucks pull that up
right well that's infamous that was i
mean this is great man apparently
there's one of joey diaz telling him he
needs to quit comedy too
man i think he just gotta retire from
everything at this point
go back to trying to get blow blowies in
your truck i don't know
although your your success rate on that
was was zero as far as we know as well
you want to come to my car and suck my
car wait is that really from yesterday
or did you have that before or last
bobby it was from bobby okay that makes
sense yeah i was like you can't have
been sitting on that that's crazy if so
suck my car
yeah
someone has a gun at my school right now
said emmy
uh uh you should
reach out you should call the police
yeah probably probably not
leaving a member
or if you have already called the police
then message someone on discord and
let's get some details there emme
after you're in a safe place and uh you
called the authorities
not here he's usually the discord person
who should who should she reach out to
they shouldn't reach out to anyone they
should call the police i say call the
police
get in a safe place
right after you've done all those things
then you can message us on discord okay
well it could be me i mean i'm on there
you can listen uh to the show dan thank
you
um oh no i'm accidentally
sorry
um
okay
so what are we doing i'm just confused
now where are
we uh oh you're looking for a clip yeah
i was looking for the
the infamous
i mean it's a long clip i don't know if
it is really i've seen it in the past
there's a clip go look for the clip i
found the episode that's from but it's
time stamp
it's them having a conversation over the
course of like 20 minutes okay whatever
anyway enough about him
uh what else
oh this okay so
before we get the
we've got oh i want to do the kilbra
tate stuff
so cobra tate
as you guys know
is one of my favorite red pill people to
make fun of because
as far as insane people insane red
people go red pill people he's the
craziest by far
like you could take all the fresh and
fit boys
and you could take all the pickup
artists in the world and nobody compares
you could take rolo tony browntown
nobody compares
to our boy tate speech
which is kind of a funny name like hate
speech tate
speech anyway he posted a picture he
posted uh
a video about me
on his main channel here
i didn't really understand the title you
look
hey y'all come look at this
[Music]
by the way you're posting pictures that
i posted
to be humorous you understand that right
not much of a deep dive there
by the way the title makes more sense if
you see the description
oh you look like a geek
you look like a human trafficker bro
you look like a geek i does anyone not
find geek that insulting i don't really
think that's that's very like kind of
old school like
bully thing like that used to be like
really insulting geek
you [ __ ] geek seems like a very like
i'm gonna put your head in the toilet
bro if i ever see you
i'm gonna give you a wedgie geek
meanwhile the police be like um you're
wanted for human trafficking
oh where's the sound oh is it because
it's do we got claim for a curveball
music yeah
again these are all pictures i posted of
myself
man that one really got me the diaper
one
haters love that one haters love that
diaper photo i gotta go back in time and
find out when did i post that what was
the context of that diaper one
they're really getting a lot of mileage
from that one
i'm on my instagram feed i gotta find
out the origins of the diaper
picture
yeah wait till they see the one where i
posted my bare ass
you know
[Laughter]
well anyway
uh well there was one
yeah one there's multiple now oh was the
james charles one when he posted his
bare ass yeah so i did the same yeah
yeah there's multiple now
oh well there's nothing wrong with this
photo is there
what's wrong with this one that my
posture isn't straight i was gonna say
if you dropped my line my alpha chakra
is way [ __ ] misaligned here
whoa
somebody said in the chat and i just
went and fact checked it okay this is
the best part here give me the sound
back
so here is go ahead dan what were you
gonna say oh just that a geek the origin
of the turn geek is it was a circus
performer that would bite the heads off
of animals
whoa that's [ __ ] metal that is way
different than i would have thought that
seems like something
tate would be into
like that's metal as hell isn't aussie
osborne
geek he's the he's the original modern
geek did it with a bat and a dove
wow
wow man
well thanks for that little tidbit
whoever dropped that in the chat i never
knew that
so what is he eating there at this
moment do we know looks like a snake
oh yeah okay legend that's i'm sorry but
if you're calling me a gee you're
calling me ba
heavy metal bro he's biting the head off
uh a cobra
oh
[Music]
zach
he's biting the head off of a cobra
dude that guy is fearless
that's wild well
ahead of a cobra yes
that's what i was well stated
very poetic
jesus
how did geek turn into nerd like a nerdy
that's what i'm beta boy this is these
guys these guys are these
are
warriors
anyway here here is uh what a fatty yeah
and here is cobra tate the human
trafficker
buddy
yo
look at this [ __ ] hell yeah
guns
airplanes
the one thing i kind of that stuck out
about this whole tate mega compilation
is that like he seems so alone doesn't
he
like
he's so insecure it's oozing off the
video
the man has no real substance i mean
look
there's like one picture of him with a
girl
there
and the rest is like him by himself like
man you have no friends or with his
brother or love
yeah with his brother
yeah this is i'm sorry but
it's oozing insecurity
is it not
like
like damn dude like
bro
car
car airplane
guns
okay cool dude i mean you're basically
like
anyone from the south
trucks guns and god
uh no offense to our friends in the
south by the way
oh yeah the comments are crazy bro it's
actually kind of disturbing there's a
good so it's got 77 000 views which is
you know
not bad
what's really interesting is
um
the amount of people that are into his
his teachings
the internet has made people have no
business talking [ __ ] so country you
know ether would never talk [ __ ] to tate
in real life
um
i i guess i would if i ever ran into him
and what do you want me to say i mean i
did it to logan paul you guys say i do
the story all the time but i did it
don't make me tell that story again
i remember the story don't make me say
it don't make me tell it again but you
know i didn't i said it
i did the thing
let me tell you about banana
but actually
ethan doesn't know he's messing with the
wrong guy this time and that might
actually be true because
you know andrew tate was on like big
brother i guess back in the day
and he got kicked off
when video surfaced of him
beating the [ __ ] it's very disturbing we
saw
or did you send it to me or no ela sent
it to me it was on our subreddit
uh just really violently beating the
[ __ ]
out of women and
to be honest people want me to tell the
logan paul story dan i see it in the
chat
don't make me do it guys i've told this
story too many times so it's been a
while
it has been a while
uh
beating the [ __ ] out of women and
locking them in rooms really violent i
mean this is not like your average guy
that we goof on on the internet like
fresh and fit or
rolo tony browntown or whatever
all the people you know
um
this man is actually a violent dangerous
criminal i mean he's human trafficking
he's holding
dozens of women seemingly against their
will
into human trafficking webcam that's how
he made his wealth is forcing women to
do webcam services and
keeping the money
this guy is actually should be in jail
and i don't and it's actually scary you
if did you watch the video i sent dan
no
you didn't see it
i didn't really want to see a woman it's
very disturbing
it's very very disturbing
so i'm not sure how much
deeper i want to take the cobra tape
thing just because
i don't think there's any good that will
come out of this tit for tat because
he's actually just
like a dangerous literal [ __ ]
criminal that should actually be in jail
and uh it's kind of
actually dude it's pretty scary
[Music]
here he's talking about drunk driving
i'm gonna do it just today okay because
it's so fun here listen to this genius i
could drink drive
a thousand times and never crash i've
done it in thailand on super bikes drunk
out my mind i have never crashed ever i
could drink drive unlimited times and
never crash but in the west street
driving's the worst thing ever because
not because of people like me who have a
brain who will drink have a bottle of
vodka get in their car drive home at
school because of the [ __ ] idiot who
will do six bottles of whiskey
crash and kill somebody
so the law isn't made for me the law is
made for the [ __ ]
isn't that what every isn't that every
drunk driver's logic like i'm one of the
good ones i'll drive the speed limit
i'll drive a million times and never get
caught
yeah that's the logic until you do
until you
too much wine sorry yeah i mean brett
kavanaugh for example ryan cavanaugh for
example
firsthand experience yeah
it's just crazy to me
i guess it's part of his charm is that
he lives in romania so he can get away
with sa
and talking about driving drunk and [ __ ]
i even seen him making the rounds on one
of my favorite twitter accounts right
wing cope
so this guy's a genius right listen to
this
you have an idea and it's been a week
where's your [ __ ] company where's
your business
it's been a week you ain't done [ __ ]
people are lazy people are slow people
are complacent including you everything
must happen instantly quickly fast speed
attack hitler conquered europe with
blitzkrieg you need to go quickly i
cannot emphasize this enough lesson one
so besides referencing hitler as a model
someone they'll kind of look up to as an
archetype which obviously you know
there's there's some problems with that
well he famously conquered europe and
then you know nothing he pretty much
lived out the rest of his days happily
ever after yeah working out really well
exactly i don't think blitzkrieg was
actually if i and i i'll have to brush
up on my history but i don't believe
that blitzkrieg ended well for uh
our our good friend
i'm pretty sure he died in a bunker
covered in [ __ ] burning gasoline and
blew him and his wife's brains out no
[ __ ] uh fiery coffin
so
not sure about that blitzkrieg there
tater tater you know
he's like listen i just want i just like
hitler i just wanted to give him a shout
out
by the way really glad he's got this
white board this this kind of
these this is really helpful i'm sure
people are paying a lot of money for
this
we got this arrow going here and two
arrows going to the right
god damn it tate you are a genius no
there's two arrows
on the left
pointing to the side those were the
french columns and that was actually the
panzerfaust or the the core that right
circled around genius cut off the supply
lines yeah genius
blitzkrieg baby
uh oh and then he of course
uh posted this article police raid mega
king of toxic manila
masculinity and human trafficking
investigation
man this guy is just a slug
so there you go i don't know what do you
guys think i shouldn't really get into
it
he's just not
he's honestly just psychotic there's so
much there's actually so much good tate
content out there though
of him being like you can actually
you can actually drive completely drunk
it's totally fine like hitler used to
drive on speed all the time and he's
actually my idol
all right people want my story
so tate's
tate's fans say i would never say it to
the face okay
well let me tell a story then
[Music]
by tater tots yeah he should change his
name to tater tot
yeah he's actually a dangerous dude this
video i saw of him beating up these
girls was really really really really
disturbing
um
so that kind of i was like oh man that's
actually like
anyway
so a long time ago
many years ago me and i dubs made a
video about uh logan paul when he was
blowing up on the internet
logan paul colorblind maybe you guys
even remember these glasses have changed
my life because
exactly
because this viral this video he made
went so viral and it was so
stupid bro
he got uh
color colorblind glasses that apparently
if you're colorblind
it can help you
visualize what uh colors look like
his tit
and me and idubbbz
agreed to do kind of a collaboration
uh lampoon lampooning this video
i want to show the clip that was super
viral
actually let me find logan paul but
anyway this video went really did really
good for us it has 22 million views
uh logan paul colorblind you guys got to
see this video it's so [ __ ] stupid
okay oh wait our video almost says as
much as his isn't that awesome 29
million
because at the time that was like mega
viral and this channel was blowing up
here what here just watch this these
glasses uh that are going to cure by
colorblindness
for the first time in my life
it's so emotional
it's such an emotional journey to wear
like these hundred dollar glasses just
add a little contrast
here here's the watches
[Music]
here it is
there's a 20 minute or 10 minute lead up
to this look at this he's just
[Music]
such a [ __ ] liar bro look at him
acting
oh my god dude
logan this is logan cam this is logan
pov
before
now
bro it did not look different did it
it's a little more saturation okay wait
before
yo
no way
you can see the fog in the distance
[Music]
what's funny is that was the tenth shot
you know they
they had to get more emotion in there
i can't
believe that i lived my whole life
missing out on stuff like this
i've never seen a sunset
anyway so we made a whole video
lampooning them
and logan got really pissed
he's like you're making fun of my
disability
and we're like dude a dis i mean okay
you know
he's like he's he's an ableist he's
making fun of my disability right i was
like all right logan you're like on top
of the world you you can't see like
green and purple chill the [ __ ] out
you know
a lot of people are color blind uh
that's you know
you you're not a paraplegic dude stop
this is like um
jada smith saying that she's disabled
because she has a self-diagnosed
alopecia
so anyway
i'm going to okay
it gets me every time
oh no
a new
a new [ __ ] thumbnail celebration
[Applause]
thumbnail
let's go
throw your hands in the air
okay
we made it shout out billy b
skinny legends
okay
throw your hands in the air billy d
getting that thumbnail again
[Music]
getting that thumbnail in again okay
let's go so he's talking about the bobby
thing that's cool
because
yeah
sick so anyway
thanks for the breaking news um
so logan got really bad and he's like yo
you guys are making fun of my disability
or whatever it's like bro yeah your
video was so corny you were faking it
like stop trying to
stop trying to be like that dude it's
not like that
yo this is real interesting this is the
new mortal kombat
don't lie you would totally pay play
this
you would 100 play mortal kombat 7 which
comes out this summer get over here
looks like my i actually might be the
final boss of this game
which is really interesting you're uh
goro
yeah right
i just need six arms can you ethan score
up please yeah can you just put six arms
on me cam
dude this looks really
good whose body did you put rogan on or
is that his real body no that's a real
photo of him yeah that's real
i know they that you shrunk him but like
that's what his body looks like why is
he standing like that i'm not a doctor
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway
so
yada yada
i'm hanging out with some friends and we
get invited to go over to one of these
notch minecraft parties
you guys know about these things i've
talked about it notch who's the
creator of minecraft sold it for like a
over a billion dollars
back then he bought i think at the time
it was the most expensive house in la
this enormous way over the top
uh opulent
mansion
so weird i mean i've talked to us a lot
of times but he brings in such a weird
crowd
it's just people trying to
network
people
low-grade models
it's like what you think about la when
you think about the bad side of la
so i'm in there
and uh i'm walking i'm kind of just
exploring the house
and it's just full of dumb [ __ ] because
this house is like 50 000 square feet
way bigger than anyone ever needs you
have to fill it with all this dumb [ __ ]
there's like a candy factory
there's like
uh
you know all these statues and [ __ ] you
have to turn it to like a museum full of
[ __ ] you don't care about to just fill
the space
and in one of the rooms
oh here
in one of the rooms there's a
antique
super here i am yeah that looks that now
that's a
that's a
formidable
opponent i've ever seen one
there's like an antique mustang bright
red bright bright [ __ ] red you know
pure bright red
and who do i see standing next to it but
logan [ __ ] paul
so i'm thinking to myself
you know usually when i meet people it's
all good we say hi
there's no problem there's no beef
so i walk over there thinking it's gonna
be all good
and i'm trying to crack you know i'm
just trying to break the ice so i go up
to logan paul next to this bright red
antique mustang and i say hey logan paul
what color is that car
[Laughter]
and he looks at me
and he doesn't laugh like i expected
i had to say it the car was so bright
red
ha
and he looks at me and he forms a fist
and he pulls it back like he wants to
hit me
and he said to me
i've imagined i've thought about so many
times what i'd say to you if i ever ran
into you
like you have pubes for beard or
something like that
that was the that's what he he really
was thinking like i'm gonna [ __ ]
burn that guy when i see him and he said
i have pubes for for beard that was his
the insult he uh
really that's what he said yeah yeah
or if you go back i think that's what he
said it was something like that
yeah you can go back when i said it i'm
not questioning it because of that i'm
just
i mean
hold on
swear to god that's what happened
yo because he is his i've always thought
his beard is like
pube yeah yeah that's pretty pure ironic
that that he would say that to you
so that that i mean that that was what
he's but honestly he was like
actually to tell the full story to give
him credit he said
i would say you have pubes for beards or
something but he said something like but
you're so fast and funny and you
probably embarrass me i think he said
something somewhat gracious like that
but he did
he was making a fist i thought i was
like oh that this guy's gonna punch me
right now like he was [ __ ] oh and i
went to shake his hand and he wouldn't
shake my hand
i said what's up dude what color is the
car and he instead of shaking my hand he
was like oh i want to punch this guy so
there you go
but to his credit he didn't punch me
you know
now that would have been a story though
i'll be coming after that and nft money
boy that's right
there you have it
that's my story so you see tate
you think tate would choke me out if i
was like hey dude where's where's uh
where's all your sex slaves
i mean maybe if he was standing with a
girl at a party i was like hey is this
your sex life what's up tate
hey tate is this girl free to go or
it's definitely more likely than with
logan paul say that yeah
he's like in romania you can just deck
people and the police don't care i
[ __ ] choked a guy out i don't know if
he's alive
love romania
for that reason
is that true in the romedia they don't
care if you like r-word people
somehow i feel like that's not true
but who knows
so we have the anyway we have the birds
aren't real guy
lined up very excited to talk to him yes
but before that actually i need to run
to the bathroom i just want to pee real
fast before we bring him in okay
so hang in there guys um
how bad you have to pee right now
uh very bad so hang in i'm gonna be
right back in just one minute and then
we're going to talk to the birds aren't
real guy okay be right back beautiful
beautiful
[Music]
yes
you got that cam
how was your weekend dan
oh my weekend was splendid
i went to the [ __ ] renaissance fair
i know a lot of people i posted a
picture of it on my instagram so i'm
sure all that the audience saw it
already pick for the gram for the gram
actually there was a pretty good meme
on the subreddit let me see if it's uh
still near the top here
ah yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow pretty good pretty good
not bad not bad did everyone have a nice
mother's day
yeah how about you did you spend it with
your mother zachary dude we did a nice
old jewish brunch you know
jewish jewish branch and that good stuff
you know
what's your thought on brent
used to be the best deli in l.a however
i've retracted fell off yeah they fell
off hard god love it god love it but
there's better it's a better deli out
there yeah
you uh well i can't really comment on
the old jewish deli thing anymore
because i haven't eaten meat in
over a decade at this point so i don't
know who has the best rube in it at this
point i'm afraid honestly the best one
right now in my opinion you've been to
mort's
i think so mort's just kind of taking
morts
down a good [ __ ] jewish deli right
across from the old jewish hospital get
a nice little smee on the bagel
forget about it forget about it hey ian
you want to uh spoil um doctor strange
for everybody
do i want to yeah
no that's lay it all out
that's kind of that's doctor what are
you afraid of
i'm so triggered by doctor strange
spoilers
yeah cam got major majorly spoiled yeah
as soon as i logged into twitter on
friday
i wasn't even following it i wasn't even
looking it up it was just one of those
like uh hey you might like the subject
it was just a major spoiler first thing
i saw lovely hey real quick
because i just opened instagram hey
ethan just real quick you'll appreciate
this ethan i just opened instagram
and this is the first post
i saw that picture i was like dude
papa what is this fit bro
it's handsome it's handsome dude
i mean the bottom half is like clown
that turns me on like baggy ass pants
with big [ __ ] feet
he's living life he's like he's like a
southern clown
looks like he's in he just needs some
makeup on
he's a rodeo
clown oh one thing i want to say before
we bring um this hoodie comes out this
thursday
i designed this hoodie
and
i'm slightly worried i'm very worried
that people are going to get mad again
because you guys remember
we made that one long sleeve
that said
i have crushing depression or something
anxiety anxiety and people got really
angry that we were glorifying
mental illness
i was like wow so we ended up donating
it all
now this one is based on my own
experience
it says
take as directed or something
on the back
but um
obviously i'm medicated and this was
something that i designed for my own
experience so i don't know
i think it looks nice though
so this is one of my designs coming out
this thursday at teddyfish.com
and hopefully we don't people get angry
because
this is my life i live this [ __ ] okay
i'm not glorifying anything where would
we be
so anyway that's exciting
there's actually a really nice
collection coming out this thursday
uh all right let's talk to the birds
the birds guy
his name is peter by the way peter
peter the birds guy
just kidding
peter mcendu macindu macindu
macadanu all right uh i'm going to let
him in give me one second to queue it up
we actually did a
a pre
pull just to uh
just to get a sense for everyone's app
are birds real
56
said
yes peter
so you have more work to do 43 only 43
said birds are not real
what are we doing about this
very disappointing
very very disappointing i think it says
more about you know
the state of our country's education
system than your audience though um you
know i think it i think it probably
probably shows us what these kids are
learning in the in the common core
system about birds and everything but uh
yeah thanks for having me on
peter
mcindel thank you for joining us the
founder of birds aren't real
i find your in your movement very
interesting um how long have you been
doing it
it's been four years now doing birds
aren't real so a bit of a long time with
the length of college yeah
and so you're all in right now are you
still focused on how far are we taking
birds aren't real we taking it all the
way
we're taking it pretty far i mean i
would say we are uh
uh
sort of at a transitional phase for
birds aren't real right now because the
first
i would say four years of doing birds
aren't real were in character so i was
like
you know playing the character embodying
the bird conspiracy theorist role and
then going on the local news or any show
like this
in character like that and so
that was sort of the goal but then last
year
the project sort of succeeded and like
all the national news started reporting
on birds don't realize if it were like a
real
movement that had been around since like
the 70s
um
so sort of used that
to take out to take myself out of
character and now it's a different
project now it's like all out of
character yeah so tell me peter where
are you from what part of the country
are you from
uh i'm from arkansas i just moved to
la actually but i'm back in the south
now
you know i'm visiting my my my my
girlfriend madeline who's sitting right
there yeah so coming from arkansas you
probably i don't i've never been to
arkansas but it's a red state you find
that you encounter a lot of kind of
these conspiracy theories or conspiracy
thinking back there is that kind of
oh yeah i mean i i grew up like you know
arkansas is a red state but i grew up
like i would say at like the reddest
reddest reddest hole in the red state i
was homeschooled growing up so i
interested it was like
homeschooled but not homeschooled just
at home i was homeschooled at like these
homeschool co-ops so like you go to
these churches and all the other
homeschool kids are there and then uh
there's sort of like a group of families
like game of thrones that kind of like
controls the homeschool community
in uh in arkansas so
that's where i grew up and yeah there's
a bunch of conspiracy theories there and
stuff that i've i guess have like
informed
the character and the project so you
grew up kind of in this i find that
interesting how did you kind of
sorry your parents into
what did they think about your project
are they more
more
less conspiratorial
in their thinking or did you kind of
break away
i don't really talk about my family
they're like
on board with the project on bro okay
that's good with birds aren't real but
you know we differ in our beliefs got it
got it that's what i'll say about that
yeah
so you grew up around this
conspiratorial thinking was there a
point where you're like this is [ __ ]
or were you kind of into it for a while
i was never into it man i mean i don't
know
i don't know what it really was growing
up i had a cousin who was like not in
that that i would see on vacations and
an uncle who would give me some cool
books to read and stuff that would kind
of break me out of that but
yeah i mean i
dude when when i was like 10 or 11 years
old i told my parents that i didn't
believe in god
and um
yeah was basically treated as if i was
possessed by a by a demon wow
that's pretty radical though for a 10 or
11 year old in that environment to make
to kind of come to that conclusion
yeah i i heard the pastor say like i
know there may be some people in this
room right now who are christians that
don't even believe in god and i remember
just being like that's that is me i
identify with that so interesting
do you remember do you remember any of
the conspiracies back then that were
floating around or kind of the crazy
stuff where you thought this is this is
kind of nuts or looking back on
oh yeah dude i mean there whenever um
mitt romney was running against obama
for president there was this
like i was like kind of a child when
this happened but there was a hard
belief that barack obama was the
antichrist right
and that if barack obama was elected in
office um this it would be lucifer's uh
plan winning and that uh barack obama so
if we wanted to prevent the antichrist
from becoming president of the united
states we needed to go out and fight and
campaign
and uh i mean yeah there's a bunch of
stuff like that you know the world is
ending all the time
um you know it's even beyond i guess
politics but just sort of
everything in general major
uh i guess like
i don't know like growing up i was told
there's major like kind of brainwash
plans at play like in the common core
school system for instance like was a
big reason
about birds
about birds exactly yeah i mean that
the uh
yeah was taught that kind of the common
core school system was like it's there
to teach you evolution and darwinism and
lies and wow uh you know the politicians
are are all in bed with all these people
and they're brainwashing kids so
um i mean yeah that's how like there's
entire communities just existing that
believe stuff like that and then they're
telling like little kids stuff like that
so it just kind of creates a systemic
echo chamber yeah that's really wow
that's got to be kind of scary and
really messed up to have
you know all those those really evil
forces at play when you're a young kid
you know to think that the antichrist is
going to become president that's a lot
to deal with in a young emotional mind
i know being being a child and worrying
about oh [ __ ] the antichrist is coming
yeah that's a lot
better watch out yeah
uh it is a lot yeah i mean there was
there was stuff like that all the time
so and i guess like until i was 16 or so
until i could drive and like actually
you know choose where i could go and
spend my time i was pretty much just in
those communities so
when birds aren't real came around
it's just sort of like
birds are it was kind of like the
variable to fill in for
that sort of logic yeah so you basically
you said when you're 16 you started
driving at what point you're left did
you start making friends or
acquaintances outside of this
this circle or kind of feel yourself
escaping or moving outside of it
uh i mean pretty early like i used to
tell people like the key to being
homeschooled is just having friends who
aren't homeschooled so you know there's
always
friends in in your neighborhood or
elsewhere that you can kind of find
normalcy in so
um that's what i did i mean i was able
to kind of like i guess officially break
out of it when i moved away from home
when i was 17 but like when i was a kid
it was just like yeah hang out with with
people in the in in the neighborhood who
are not you know talking about the
antichrist and how the new disney movie
is trying to put you know gay thoughts
in our brain and stuff like that yeah
that's that is true that one's true
actually
there's actually some research to back
that up yeah
i tried to have sex with dan actually if
i after i watched the new uh
after i watched the new uh toy story i
don't know what's a new thing to
thousands of people yeah
can i ask though i'm always curious
about this when it comes to uh
you know people that are
diving in head first into these
really outlandish conspiracy theories
like obama's the antichrist when
obama leaves office and the world hasn't
ended and now it's been like
going on eight years since he's been in
office how do they just
pretend like they never said that
like how do you how do they reconcile
there's sort of no way for these
communities to lose right because if
obama gets elected and then like you
know say that okay the world fell apart
i'm like oh we were right you know but
then right um if obama is elected and
nothing bad happens
and maybe some things be better like
what happened then a prayer worked
the prayer worked exactly yeah that's
awesome thank god you know so there's
really no situation that you can be
wrong in you know then so really yeah
it's just kind of this perpetual crisis
uh that never that never stops yeah
right but never arrives either it's just
always impressive it kind of reminds me
of 1984 how there's like perpetual
crisis
to control people you know yeah yeah
fake wars happening all the time i don't
know if you've read 1984 but that's like
it's totally what's going what's going
on right now yeah on the back of the
birds aren't real van actually we have
just as the judgment day may 16 2009 um
right
when when people ask me i just tell them
it's a day that i felt really judged you
should update that every year
so it's always coming
i was inspired by an actual conspiracy
theory van i saw that had that exact
date on it that's awesome
we're well past the end of the world at
this point a decade ago yeah so i mean i
don't know maybe that person thinks
they're like left behind or something
you know so you said when you were 17
you moved away so where did you move to
uh i moved to college i went to
fayetteville arkansas at the at the u of
a which is actually a really cool part
of arkansas i'd like to say that on
record fayetteville and bentonville in
like northwest arkansas is like the blue
dot in arkansas so they it's just a very
different culture there i guess a lot of
them had a bunch of world of warcraft
friends oh really playing world of
warcraft good wow players out there that
were from fayetteville arkansas shout
out from fayetteville
so you moved uh to college at 17 what
are you majoring in
uh i was majoring in psychology okay
i didn't i didn't really know what to do
yeah that's yeah i feel you big time
so you're there
and at what point are you kind of what's
that experience for you is it like a
culture shock going from from
you know being incubated in that
situation and then going out to college
which is generally
uh colleges are generally kind of more
liberal i don't know about in that
startup part of the world but people are
more open to stuff in college i would
say in general right
uh
i mean i guess so yeah i guess it just
depends on the circles that you're
around there were certainly people i
encountered there who were not
open-minded at all but yeah you know i
guess there's people there that that
we're good too and i mean i don't know
i've always like leading up until
college like all throughout high school
i've just been like i guess progressive
and
so moving there was refreshing that i
could find more of those people but
um yeah and i i i didn't last there for
long i dropped out after a couple years
whenever i started doing birds aren't
real so when did the birds aren't real
idea kind of come to be
uh
totally by accident it was not like
on purpose it came to be in
2017 or so
and
was started
really as like a prank like i was in
memphis tennessee
visiting some friends and
i didn't know it but it was the same day
as the women's march like i get shortly
after donald trump got elected and um
i was just like hanging out climbing
some buildings with some friends in
downtown memphis and we saw this like
rally happening this march uh and it was
the woman's march and there were counter
protesters there too looks like magga
dudes that were just yelling and stuff
and so
uh i basically just went in and started
trolling the
the rally just the whole the whole thing
and i just wanted i just thought it'd be
funny if there was a sign that had
nothing
i don't know i guess i thought it was
funny if there was a sign there that had
nothing to do with anything that was
going on and so i just like grabbed a
poster off a wall wrote birds on reel on
it because it was the most random thing
i could think of and started walking
around with the sign and as i did people
would ask me what the sign meant
and
i just kind of made it up as i went and
was like oh they're robots like in the
sky and like what what is this it's like
oh it's a movement that's been around
for 50 years and that is how it started
so was there people at the rally that
were genuinely interested in your
movement like were you interacting with
the women's march people and the maga
people
yeah yeah so who was it was anyone real
interesting you're like damn this is
actually this is actually something
people might believe
people i think we're just confused right
right
nothing to do with what was going on i
just thought it was funny if there was a
guy in the middle of the rally holding
up a sign really passionately because
all you can see
in a rally is the backs of signs just
like white with no words so like
theoretically he could have thought he
was at the right rally
um
and people would just ask me what it uh
what it meant it seemed that people kind
of like got it too there were certain
people just got that it was trolling
then other people took it like oddly
seriously i just i guess right
tone of the place was super serious
right so
um yeah i just responded with with equal
sincerity and uh as i was doing that
somebody was filming me my friend ally
actually um who i did not know
at the time and she ended up like
putting that video up and it went like
like memphis viral like 901 viral so
then the city of memphis just really
gathered around this idea of like birds
aren't real wait the city embraced it
the city and brit i know that sounds
wild to say interesting
they embraced it because i went back to
fayetteville to go to school and started
getting all these videos sent to me of
like high school cafeterias like
chanting birds aren't real
incredible
spray paint so i'm watching it from
class like
okay wow something is starting in
memphis and like i'm not there
and i was just fascinated by it and
wasn't a huge fan of college and just
wanted to see
what would happen if we could build like
a fake
movement that the world thought was real
so
you saw it resonating with a lot of
people and you thought hey this is
actually a thing
yeah and we might be able to create a
fake movement
what was your purpose behind wanting to
make that a fake movement when you're
like birds aren't real this is
resonating people think this is funny
what was your what was your thinking in
like why
why take it to the next level
uh i would say a couple reasons like i
was really just curious about it in the
first place that like people were so
about that idea it's like why um
and then
i just saw sort of a potential for
making a character out of it and sort of
like this fake
world
i wanted to make conspiracy theory
because like the joke itself like birds
or robots like became not funny like
after a week of saying it you know like
it's just like uh birds are robots birds
aren't real
but
i think the interesting thing to me
about it was the thought of like
building a history out under that and
kind of like that statements like the
tip of the iceberg just like a lot of
like conspiratorial statements are and
then you actually go underneath the
iceberg and i go holy [ __ ] there's a lot
here so my friend connor came on with me
and he's like he's like a historian so
he wrote out a whole history for birds
unreal and how the cia planned it and
what they did and
um we viewed it sort of like uh
and i don't even know what to call it
honestly we didn't really have like a
for sure plan or like oh we're gonna
make a
satire of conspiracy or whatever you
know it was just sort of leaning into
the energy of memphis and then just
seeing what would happen after we made a
character in a history yeah so you guys
spent time doing this history
you kind of decided to become this
character so where did you guys take it
from there did you keep did you start
attending more rallies filming content
like what was your plan to blow it up
basically we just try to make it feel as
real as possible because we realize that
there's a lot of word of mouth around
conspiracies and that there's certain
ideas that just live in culture um like
flat earth you know like the people but
like there weren't too many conspiracies
that people could just like
look at like or like list off you know
so like our our initial goal was like
let's start a movement that makes it to
where like the bird robot people or the
thought of birds being robots is is a
is just like a widely spread and known
idea and that was the initial purpose so
we started with flyers we started with
billboards and local news appearances
that the billboards were so we put up
billboards intentionally sort of in
towns where there was not a whole lot
going on right um so the baseline was
low in that town for like crazy things
all right and then when a billboard went
up they said birds aren't real because
so little is going on uh we get that
that was news we're invited on the local
news yeah that's awesome i'm smart
then then then i go on the local news
and i'm in character you know so i'm
like you know back there with the
secretary and character and you know
with everybody being miked up in
character just being a total like freak
backstage and then getting on and
continuing that and then we ended up
hiring actors so we hired this like old
decrepit man to play an ex-cia agent who
was like a part of it back in the day
and we had him like
on video like talking about it as if it
were real you know and then like an
interview that you posted on youtube or
something
yeah yeah the way that we posted on our
youtube let me pull this up what's your
youtube channel
uh it's just birds aren't real or is
that real baby
his name is eugene price he's a man he
was actually in charge of destroying the
evidence uh and had just spent
countless sleepless nights he's felt
really guilty you know
about all these birds dying
um
so you so this theory is that you guys
killed all the real birds and replaced
them with robots
yup that's the theory um or the truth
depends on it's the truth i mean he's
saying it
right so let's just get a little sneak
peek here give us some on your
background
well i started off in the military this
guy's awesome i love it i believe
everything he says already
this guy does
he was so prepared he showed up with no
with note cards his name's jerry lewis
actually
wow jerry lewis
what a legend
he showed up pulled up to the airbnb and
it did a day notice
and um we went down to meet him in
dallas and he he killed it uh but yeah
he's got that he's got that old man uh
uh respectability he's got the
you know he looks like he's been through
some stuff yeah
got some hope still in his eyes yeah
yeah
he's not done yet yeah right
he's basically you know who he is he's
the ufo guy that's been on joe rogan all
over the place what's his [ __ ] name
he's not bob lazar yeah but total he's
bob lazar of birds aren't real exactly
let me show the people a short little uh
clip here and after i got out of the
military i was uh doing security for the
cia
i was in dc in uh 72.
and then they moved me into domestic
intelligence
and that's why i was there that
well i saw some things that i i really
wish i hadn't seen
are you
referring to bird drone surveillance
yeah
wow tell us some more about that oh yeah
like i said i i've been with the cia for
a few years
and then one morning i got ordered to
report to a military base
and i was briefed on something called
operation water the country and when i
got for those who don't know what that
is um can you explain what that is
oh sure it's a code name we use for the
process of removing all the living birds
they used to poison gas dropped from
airplanes
very disturbing
it's pretty it's pretty shocking that
that is horrific
yes
trigger warning before before playing
that
um
pretty serious [ __ ] man i don't know
so you guys have really went to work
trying to turn this into a real
conspiracy so you you did the work you
went to the local news you put up the
posters you put out videos like this was
there a point during all that when
you're like holy [ __ ] this is actually
happening
um
yes there was i mean there was a certain
point
when
i don't even know when just like the
news started reaching out to us and i
started doing all these in-character
interviews
and then like i think the daily beast
was like the first one to reach out to
us and i did this like two hour phone
call with this journalist whoa
trying to figure out
if
i was for real or not so let me ask you
were these reporters taking you
seriously at all or did they were they
on the fence like they couldn't figure
it out what was your what was your read
i mean this was like almost like
pre-memification
of like birds aren't real i guess which
like i don't even look at as like a meme
but people have made memes about
and
so before that it wasn't really like a
joke it was just kind of like an
opportunity to report on like this new
fringe group you know um
and so yeah they were like talking with
me
totally seriously and i mean these
conversations would last for a long time
to really try to pull poke holes in the
story but because
that's awesome
in history we built out and everything
like it was we were sort of an answer
for everything and i kind of honestly
see how like
politicians can do it in a way because
i've been doing this for so long now
that when i'm in character and people
ask me a question i pretty much know the
questions like you're ready
any question that could be asked you
know and then i know
where to bring it after the next one
okay let me ask you this birds are
referenced in the bot oh wait no that
does that answers it because they were
wiped out in the center
afterward but bird drone surveillance is
prophesied in the indeed it was
in the gnostic gospel of enoch
the egyptian god horus actually um
okay let me ask you this who's laying
eggs
what what am i eating for breakfast
uh you're you're you're eating synthetic
meat if you like oh i thought they were
eggs underneath a lot of the nests
actually there's always chicken farms
but no one's picking up the nests and
looking underneath because no one asks
any questions in this gym in this
generation you go pick up a nest and
look under and look underneath it uh
there's actually a pipe system kind of
like the suck tubes at the bank you know
pop money down and they just pop eggs
up into the nests um
pretty routinely because i mean if the
government wiped out all the birds and
then birds suddenly stopped having eggs
and eggs suddenly became
suspicious yes yeah their whole plan is
ruined they're not stupid you know so
yeah makes makes a lot of sense you know
it's funny
what's so good about the birds aren't
real thing is like it's not really
crazier than flat earth
no it's no it's really not
no yeah i mean that was the goal like
whenever we were starting birds aren't
real people would be like oh is this are
you doing like a comedy project like
what like what would you compare
yourself to and like i didn't want to i
don't know i wasn't like thinking about
it like we were competing with like
other comedy groups or anything i was
basically competing with flat earth in
terms of yeah that was perfect and those
people were for real so
i think it was just a perfect timing on
that so you started doing all these
interviews it's getting more and more
notorious
notoriety
is there a point
when
you're like have i created a monster is
this going too far did you ever have
regret like because there's got to be
thank you there's got to be people who
out there who believe this right
uh i haven't met anyone who believes it
most
most real conspiracy theorists
look at
like kind of the only real conspiracy
theory i've seen come out of birds
aren't real is that we are a psyop
it's a discredited new jersey theory oh
that now that that
yeah good luck disproving that dude yeah
i mean i had no comment on on that but
the um
yeah the majority of our audience seems
to understand the role play i didn't
know what to compare it to for a while
because we do these rallies where like
people will show up in the hundreds you
know
yeah it's basically larping
almost like
pro wrestling in a certain way
because people follow these storylines
on social media you know they follow the
arcs the character goes through and
because like with with the eugene price
video with you with the old man video we
didn't just like
make that video we like launched a
nationwide search for eugene price and
like faked a news story that his name
was brought up in and then like our
following started putting up posters
like all around the country and it
became kind of this immersive
experience so by the time that video
came out uh you know the audience had
been a part of the story themselves um
and uh
yeah so i mean i guess yeah larping roll
role role-playing or or pro it's gotta
be a facebook group somewhere that
believes birds aren't real you know what
i mean they've got to be out there
yeah they i mean they probably are i
think there's probably anything out
there um but i mean that was a
consideration with coming out of
character was like okay i don't want
20 years from now this to evolve into
something weird you know so
i ended up
yeah coming i mean after it was reported
on by the nate by like kind of national
news um that it was a real movement that
had been around since the 70s
um it was kind of having a resurgence
then we're like okay let's come out of
character so we were able to do that
sort of in a big way like with the new
with the new york times and um wow okay
so you
did you coordinate with them or how did
you manage to come out of character
in kind of uh in that moment in
collaboration with new york times
well i could sort of choose when to come
out of character because
at the same time vice have been trying
to get in touch with me to make a
documentary and so
they
had been trying to make a documentary
for three years about
birds aren't real and i would just talk
with them in character again and again i
was hoping they would do a documentary
where i was like in character and i
could build they didn't want that a fake
world but yeah they just didn't want
that so which is you know fine um so
the good thing about that though is that
like whenever we decided to come out of
character we could just hit vice back up
like hey hello okay interesting
and around that same time i don't know
if like
i don't know how that works but around
that same time taylor taylor lorenz from
the new york times we
reached out
and
get the
story which shout out taylor so
um so that was your big kind of coming
out moment where you did a story with
new york times with taylor
and how was the response to that how did
that go for you guys
uh
it's been interesting i mean like i'm
really not used to talking out of
character i guess you know so it's been
a weird experience and like i hadn't
really tried to like
i don't know i guess like
intellectualized birds aren't real or
like really like try to like i'd never
set bathroom like we're making a satire
of this or this or this you know um so
it was interesting kind of like through
that experience like seeing how
the ideas like communicated i guess to
people and i was worried about i didn't
know if people would like hate us
because we've been intentionally
spreading misinformation for
as hard as we could um
so
i think it was communicated in in all
the right
ways and like since then it's been great
honestly like people seem to like
understand the projects more and are
kind of like getting on board with it
more and so
now honestly it's less about birds
unreal and more about like this
character you know and kind of the world
that this character deals and who who
who this character
uh knows and what's what do you want
what he wants to do um
yeah it's pretty incredible you know i
got the i don't know if you were
listening but
i decided to reach out i watched 60
minutes every week i loved that show
and they had a whole feature piece on
you
and i thought it was so interesting but
60 minutes that's kind of like the
pinnacle of news
in in america so i feel like from the
new york times to 60 minutes i even
heard you on howard stern i didn't i
missed that i listened but apparently
you called in
um you kind of made the rounds of all
this mainstream media that's pretty
that's pretty crazy
yeah it's it's been very crazy yeah i
asked you a question
yeah
do they pay you 60 minutes to feature
you
no [ __ ]
not a
not a dollar have any of these people
paid you have you been able to make any
money off this because you dropped out
of school how are you supporting
yourself
uh we sell shirts on the website trying
to get the trying to get the youtube
going we started uh show called the
truth report that's like my character's
news show so on birds aren't real
website or on the youtube channel yeah
it's on it's on the birds aren't really
youtube um so birds aren't real on
youtube and then where can people buy
shirts
which i have linked in there
dot com you can buy activism apparel
although after 60 minutes it's all sold
out so oh for real oh yeah
so that's the cool thing about the 60
minutes well that's nice that they
actually their audience is is there i
was i was gonna
rep your merch but [ __ ] it's all gone
bro when's that [ __ ] coming back
i don't know man i hope soon we were
doing it all ourselves in arkansas with
shelves and stuff but what happened
well it just got to the point kind of
after coming out of character where it
was couldn't handle it so we literally
had like a room rented out in arkansas
like just like doing everything
ourselves um
but yeah now we're like making the move
over to los angeles and kind of getting
partners but i can get you this is dope
this is sick
thank you
i designed that one thank you bird
drones of north america that's [ __ ]
sick thank you
i'm really i'm proud of that the aquatic
sentry stealth attack drone
yes that's honestly such a good shirt
is the blue bird on there the retina
the retina scanner bluebird yeah that's
why they make a blue it's so blue so you
look at it and uh such a great design
man
thank you man i designed that and then
the birds the birds work for the
bourgeoisie
yeah with a nice little bird going going
to work and and the nice and the nice
good march man you guys crushed it on
this
well well thank you that was the first
shirt we ever made that i am a lie one
um
was actually made for a video when we
made a video from birds aren't real in
1987 from the movement of the this is
great this looks awesome
by the way you guys have a copyright on
birds aren't real and all that [ __ ]
you've done all that right
we do yeah we got it a while ago um just
because when i went whenever we started
doing it it was like uh
everything was available and all the
websites and usernames that's so sick
that's so good i'm glad you got all that
by the way i don't know how familiar you
are with us but we have a brand teddy
fresh i don't know if you're familiar
would you be down to do a collab birds
aren't real teddy fresh collab because i
[ __ ] love the aesthetic
of all this [ __ ]
that would be so sick and i am familiar
i've actually been watching you since
high school oh thanks dude that's
awesome shout out
shout out so i'll take credit for your
development
and from adolescence to adulthood
thank you for the worry let's be in
touch because i actually do want to do a
birds aren't real collab because this
[ __ ] [ __ ] slaps hard dude and i
stand by your move i look at the truth
out there we do we design it all
ourselves my me and my friend connor who
does birds with me so thank you so much
that means a lot yeah dude you got that
christmas swag birds aren't real don't
trust the partridge and the pear tree
that's sick
i trust the partridge in the pear tree
yeah it is odd how much of that song is
about birds it's all about [ __ ] birds
dude think about it a lot of weird bird
stuff out there yeah people don't think
about it man
i know you gotta oh open your eyes
so you kind of you you're i feel like
your project succeeded beyond your
wildest expectations is that true
i would say so
yeah which is something i'm still
processing but it's been it's been a
ride for sure yeah and it's like at this
transitional point now like okay we just
came out of character kind of starting
this new
phase of it so you're gonna try it
sounds to me like you kind of want to
build out this character this conspiracy
theorist character
uh into some kind of show format or
something like that
really just want to flesh it i mean the
eventual goal will be to not do birds on
real forever you know it's been four
years now but there's a bunch of other
ideas for projects that we have so
um
for the time being yeah it's building up
those birds aren't real character who
you know if he believes birds aren't
real then what else does he believe it's
kind of like using the extensions of
that
so are you thinking of maybe starting a
new conspiracy theory and repeating the
formula or you want to create media
around this character kind of like
what's your long-term goal now
well
right now the the way that the idea of
birds are real has existed has been on
social media which like we kind of
looked at that like a new form of
storytelling you know kind of like how i
feel if i'm following 300 people like
they're all telling me their stories all
the time so we tried to tell the story
of birds aren't real the same way with
kind of like like on instagram on social
media like a long soap opera or like
like
autobiographical reality tv just kind of
like showing what's happening in our
lives but there's never been like a
package things like this is birds you
know like this is birds not real so
we want to make a movie and a book kind
of a duck yeah that that's that sounds
like a really good idea
and then for the time being my character
started a news show he's moving out to
to california in the story line of birds
aren't real this is not real life and
the storyline of birds aren't real my
character just got a manager who's
totally using him and gaslighting him
and this manager wants him to make a
make a news show so he's moving him out
to hollywood after the big new new york
times story um and my character is going
to make a news show out there so we just
put out the first
two episodes called the truth report and
that's sort of the way to like
get more into like what is this
character's life like what does he do
who does he spend time around
um
while at the same time being the public
information officer for the birds aren't
real movement trying to find your
channel here
let's see you got two new episodes guys
go watch it now on the birds aren't real
channel
the truth report episode 102. that is
wes watson
exposing the taylor laurens of course
the girl who exposed you in the new york
times
right yeah because the way we handled
all the out of character moments
and the way that we would handle this on
the instagram page if people asked about
it where we would say i got deep faked
and so whenever the vice documentary
came out or anything like that like they
deep faked us and the deep state
basically activated the media they like
hit the button like
this movement's getting too big smear
them everywhere so
then you know you like you were saying
all the mainstream i guess assistant if
you mentor howard stern or whoever
um it's like how else do you explain
that other than the deep state telling
people to shut this down you know
convince all all of the public that it's
a joke it's like psychological so this
isn't you right now this is a deep fake
of a government agent
yes right now i i am a i am a deep fake
and underneath this face is a is an
actor
right
jack harlow looking actor who who
i i patched my face on yes
well peter
um
i think it's really exciting really cool
what you're doing
keep it up i'm i'm sure we'll we'll keep
seeing more from you
it's incredible it's incredible what a
funny little idea can how far that can
take you i think you've proven
that
it's certainly been a testament to what
happens if you just keep leaning into
something sure yeah
yeah absolutely keep cleaning yeah but
how old are you by the way
oh i just turned 24 last week
so there you go
nice fresh ripe age of 24. very ripe
very
very lots of conspiracies in your future
man
but there you have it birds aren't real
on the on the webs
there's no merch available but uh you
guys have like a newsletter so people
can get reminded if it gets in stock or
anything like that
we do yeah on the website there's a
newsletter thank you and uh i'll be in
touch too i'll
i'll get one of you guys says his
content yeah i mean we've been talking
but i i have his email
anyway keep it up man it's awesome what
you're doing
super cool stuff
take care dude nice chatting all right
peter uh mcendu of birds aren't real
in deep fake as a government agent
thank you bro
take care nice chatting god bless
that was great
you rocks
shout out birds aren't real
yeah well i think i know why i have a
fear of birds now they're robots oh i
should have asked him about that yeah um
i had been running a poll during the
latter half of this interview where i
asked again are birds reel and it has
uh flipped it's now 51 saying no
49 yes so we've convinced at least a few
in the audience itself flipped
the thing is
if he is a government agent
i don't he just told us he just came out
of character but then he revealed he
might be a deep fake government agent so
i honestly don't know what to believe
right
but well he's definitely got that
element correct on the uh
the conspiracy theory world that there's
always there's always another layer
deeper right and there's always another
layer like i said at the top of the show
about crater these crater earth people
are making fun of the flat earthers
you morons
that's interesting as upbringing though
you know because i had a feeling that he
might come from
that world that type of world and he
really came from the deep deep
conspiracy world yes indeed so there you
go shout out peter interesting dude yeah
uh cool guy
i can't wait to do that collab man
that's that merch was [ __ ] swag for
sure
well there you go what a nice calling
from peter
birds aren't real we're basically the
new 60 minutes he's on 60 minutes
we're right there
i'm ethan klein and this is
30 minutes
30 minute interview
it was about 30 minutes wow
great great name
well
there you have it
what else is there
there's uh
this johnny depp amber heard stuff
there's uh
avatar two actually by the way
i have some exciting little breaking
news that i want to share with you oh
yeah
i'm gonna wait until after the show but
it's so exciting wait we have to wait
till after the show why are you [ __ ]
teasing everyone
well it it's news for you
well i guess it's news for everyone i
don't know
the
tick tock uh defense attorney
knew him
he we had reached out to him
he just got back to us he said he'd love
to come up yes
america's favorite lawyer yes let let's
go
let's go
yes where is he located
los angeles oh he's in l.a let's go
yeah
yeah so
we will have to uh get that worked out
no no details yet but uh does he have
any i was just thinking about him i
wonder if he has any new tick tocks up
because we watched all of them there's a
brand new one today pull it up baby
let's go
let's go
let's go
let's go
america's favorite
criminal defense attorney
did you just say pull it up baby he did
say pull it up baby i'm going to call
him
can someone send me the link i got i'm
rocking the tats so
let's go let's go someone could just
send me the link i'll i can uh yeah let
me uh
was it on his uh instagram or his tick
tock because tick tock i assume right
tick tock yep
[Music]
you got it all right thank you thank you
ma'am
[Music]
all right
here we go under 21 year old dui
reduced to reckless driving let's go
let's go
all right we're right outside of
alhambra courthouse where we just
crushed this dui case our great client
was under 21 and you know was had a
little bit of alcohol but
wait under 21 that sounds bad
i don't think you're allowed to drink
under 21. well yeah
that element as well we're able to work
out a really great deal we got the dui
charges dismissed and all he's taking
away today
how do you get a dui charge dismissed
the man was driving drunk
i just i just love the leaf blowing yeah
great place to record this video guys
you know i i'm like i'm i think our
criminal justice system is totally
[ __ ] but i think the one thing we can
all unite against is drunk drivers let's
go
let's go
i just got this dude this drunk driver
back on the road
it really is i love this special about
about the drunk driving angle today is a
reckless driving which can get wiped
from his record after one year from
today how do you feel i feel amazing
honestly um i thought my day was going
to be ruined but thank you to david and
all worked out
all right let's go
i love him man i love him
i'm so excited to talk to him
and
pandp firm 2.0 what happened to 1.0 damp
well that's what and yeah i was
because i knew that handle but it wasn't
popping up on tick tock i'm guessing he
might have
caught a band at some point
wait let's go wait is this how we got a
hold of him we commented on his tick
tock
uh
hey david we'd love your tick tocks any
time we actually responded to the dm we
had sent on instagram let's go david
let's go
someone said imagine this guy in oj's
trial
my great client here is accused of
decapitating his uh wife and uh
her lover
i'm super happy to say that today
he's been fully acquitted with johnny
cochran yeah one of these tech dogs [ __ ]
johnny cochran i'm all about david from
panda p firm 2.0
i love these memes i see here bro is
keeping gotham alive so true
it's so true
i [ __ ] love this guy so much
well that's exciting good job dan it'd
be interesting to do a content court
with him
oh he'll defend any criminal yeah that
that should be our go-to that's really a
funny idea zach
that's funny my great client here is
accused of of scamming people at a
boxing event
he's gonna defend the ace family yeah
i'm happy to announce that he was in
debt 20 million dollars
and we've got the court to basically
remove all dats from him
let's go
let's go
he loves his job he seems like he really
loves his job you know they say
you love what you do you never work a
day in your life
sort
of
kind of
you know there was this elon musk to it
that really got me thinking
where's that one about him if he shows
up dead
oh
i think it's in here
oh here it is
elon's been
[ __ ] posting as always
he said if i die under mysterious
circumstances
it's been nice knowing you i haven't
really been following i don't know is
this a reference to something specific
he got into some beef with the russians
or something what happened hmm
i don't know just being dramatic
no there was something with russia yeah
died well it's true russians don't play
putin just
take people out
with isotopes and [ __ ]
vladimir what was it that happened with
russia
well
i didn't know he did it but
he uh he posted about it on his twitter
there's a long text
well anyway this tweet got me thinking
he says
i said
if i died me ethan klein died showed up
murdered somewhere
died under mysterious circumstances
there would be so many suspects
you do have a lot of enemies i was like
man that's kind of [ __ ] up like
there'd be like
six primes there'd be like six serious
[Music]
six serious suspects if i died
if i just
if i showed up in an alley like beat to
death who would you suspect first
ian
yeah yeah
all those peeing jokes all those kanye
west he's finally gonna punch him over
the edge
no i'm serious let's make a list
uh right now i would collaborate
yeah um jeff's friend
i i mean he did
he i mean
this would probably go to him first
since there's a record at this we're
cool now
but i'm saying if you're investigating
my death
you got the tate brothers
you got jeff's friend you got ryan
cavanaugh
they'd ask they check with ryan
cavanaugh you know i'd put him as
private suspect number one yeah he's got
he's got a motive
but not worried about ryan cavanaugh i'm
just saying though they did they would
investigate yeah probably they would go
question currently embroiled in four
lawsuits with him yeah he's got a
motivation man that website's staying up
does ryan cavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein
we're working on an update by the way to
celebrate our victory right yeah
big
good news
somebody said a deranged h3 fan honestly
that's probably the right answer
just saying
just saying
keemstar
trisha
i don't think those people would kill me
no
but i'm just saying if you're the police
you gotta follow up every lead yeah
no it's true yeah
that's kind of [ __ ] up
brendan schwab
and schwab now you know
boogie someone said
that's true and he has been known
to uh flaunt a deadly weapon that's true
what's with boogie man he made like one
really mean tweet about me and i just
muted him on twitter
because i didn't want to see his [ __ ] my
verified tab
he's been cheating on me like non-stop
for like a month
it's pretty crazy
nothing like a lover scorned oh
he was a lover
shredder
shredder
yeah but you know oh [ __ ] too nice there
oh okay rolo tony fresh and fit shoe
nice shoe nice would definitely oliver
tree
philly d
uh-huh
matt hawk matt haas
you know that guy's holding a grudge he
could you know he might just be waiting
and plotting the perfect time to kill me
they'll get pinned on someone else
philly would never he needs to clickbait
right he would lose so much from killing
me
that's true
we can rule philly dl
yeah
no philly d is not my enemy he's a he's
a skinny legend
we love philly dude
yo oliver david bill burr
nah
why was bill burke killing me yeah
patrice wilson
patrice wilson well there's some
evidence that
he's implying something
so there you go i'm just saying isn't
that kind of crazy
just saying there'd be there there would
be like 10 suspects in my murder people
saying the stroller
the cursed stroller
definitely
quartering
[Music]
tim open head pool
that's pretty funny though
jimmy lee nah come on
crowder you think crowder would want to
kill me samantha b now might want to
kill me samantha b james charles might
have a hit jordan peterson might have a
hit
look at all these people wendy williams
for crazy you know right
die
just saying
just saying
my dad might stab me like a beach ball
in a sleeping sleepwalking state
somebody saying my dad
just saying
just saying yeah i don't know if i need
to relax on
making enemies all the time maybe
there's like a million people that want
me dead
no
the ghost of mobility mary
right
just saying
people saying me
dan
never know definitely gotta ask him he's
close to me
right you know ask the people closest to
him
okay y'all just y'all just praying for
me to die at this point
everyone's just spamming names of people
that are going to kill me
you asked for it the ceo of youtube yeah
so me and you elon musk you know
hey if there's an army people trying to
kill you then you're not doing something
right
is that the same
all right what are we going to talk
about we got uh well this logan paul
we were goofing on this thing that logan
paul did
he finally launched this nft project and
we talked about this a little while ago
now the nft economy is completely
collapsed
i mean not completely but it is then
overall it's dropped a lot much so
broken though um it's dropped like a
thousand percent you know i'm pretty
sure this is just
uh going oh you know oh i didn't know
this
wait what is this
perks
100 of the proceeds go to ukraine
war relief
yeah i don't know if that's just for
this particular one uh for the first one
here or if that's for the entire project
oh it's gotta be just for this one
because you know this guy's trying to
get paid
but that's nice anyway
i mean what the [ __ ] even is this photo
oh is this people yes
yeah nobody wants that [ __ ] bro
i mean 8 000 is a lot
don't get me wrong
i mean that's 17 hours left that will
grow up way more i think i think it's
going to be at least 50 ethereum this
morning when it dropped or before the
show was at three three do you get the
damn polaroid of course not dan why
would you get the polaroid
you get a picture of the polaroid
[Music]
no dude the physical the polaroid itself
is worthless what are you talking about
who would want that
you can lose it it can get destroyed
you have to handle it oh i have a
polaroid what am i going to do with that
no dude you're going to lose that on the
blockchain is the polaroid on the block
j no
you can lose the nft click on the wrong
link
that's true
that's not secure
man people bought lost billions of
dollars because they're [ __ ] hard
drive down um
i don't have all the details on hand but
i was reading about the other day that
uh
open c like the biggest nft
network or whatever yeah um
had their socials i think it was their
disorder their instagram or both got
hacked
uh last week
and then they
sent out official looking things from
the accounts themselves to people that
when they clicked on it stole all their
stuff wait there was another huge nft
crypto yeah i think ultimately it wasn't
like the grand sum of what was stolen
wasn't as much as you think but that
might be because the market's crashing
um
you know six months ago it might have
been
a lot more valuable what got taken but
yeah it's not doesn't seem particularly
uh secure
well you know we liked his project until
he made it into like a whole weird nft
thing
so i'm going to be following this there
you go love said 10 eth stolen so that's
it yeah
i do believe it was only their discord
getting hacked was it just the discord
okay yeah yeah that's what i heard
google it before you uh say that because
yes it did
what
somebody in the comment that didn't
happen damn
it did
i do oh you're talking to someone in the
comments got it oh
so let's see you know
i'm really curious to see as this moves
on i mean you got 99
i got a feeling that this somewhere in
the middle is just going to start
dropping off [ __ ] hard bro
because
i mean the cryptos crashing the nfts are
crashing
well let's see it'll be interesting
you know
just saying just saying
yeah people this guy here he's in the
photo actually
is the only one that actually got paid
from this [ __ ] this guy sold at nft for
30 million bucks at like the height of
the [ __ ] dude this guy is just
killing it by the way i'm a fan of his
art
people's really cool
i'm pretty sure whoever paid 30 million
for that ain't gonna [ __ ] it's not gonna
be worth anything he actually sold a one
for 69 million
oh was that the one with all of his uh
yeah so why is he
referencing listen
yeah why is he referencing that one here
i don't know
okay well anyway i'll be i'll be
watching you logan paul what color is
that [ __ ] what color is the sweater
what color is people's sweater logan
exactly you don't [ __ ] know
i'm a mother freaking blueberry
i don't even know what a blueberry is if
you're colorblind oh no i'm a strawberry
um
what's this mobile game you found sam
this sounds interesting
you just found a new crazy mobile game
was this the ad you got on instagram
i get like 15 of those a day
i have no idea the king's choice
one million views
greetings getting married and having
children are so real in this game
so do you ever click them why do you
keep getting these ads are you
downloading these games i think because
i click on yeah you take debate and she
was sending them to me and i think the
fact that she's like sharing them too oh
yeah that that like sharing huge
engagement engaged
the king's choice
all right little lady
oh yeah
get pregnant
[Music]
what in the [ __ ]
so the queen just [ __ ] the gardener is
that what happened
see i don't think she's the queen but uh
[Music]
black baby
what the [ __ ] but the parent the guy
that she slept with well i guess she'd
been sleeping around dan he wasn't the
only one
it said cockaroo
turn her ass to stone
[Music]
play now
who's playing this culprit tate
cockaroo
that's what the bird said when he found
out
something that chad just said oh no i
play this game
so wait is it just like a uh let me
guess it's just like a uh
dating simulator no the real game is
like
um oh oh jewel what is it called
where you just drop [ __ ] yeah candy
crush yeah someone download it i
guarantee the real game's just candy
crush kings
it's always something completely
different yeah
so what in the [ __ ] dude
that's just crazy what are the comments
man i want to i want to learn more about
this game the hacking dog
the what's the king's choice to kill his
wife and baby and
illegitimate baby
it does
from the screenshots it looks like this
one is maybe a little bit closer to pull
it up what is actually being depicted
there
yeah we got a gameplay trailer let's go
let's let's go
all right here we go king's choice
take me away
[Music]
on a dreary winter day the gardener
[ __ ] my wife
i decided to kill her and the baby
[Music]
yeah this is dramatic okay
you've occupied the throne for way too
long
wait
that's the kingdom building game and
wait what the [ __ ] that ad then
they just make the crazy it's just
supposed to catch your attention which
it did i mean but the game has nothing
to do with [ __ ] your wife having
black babies
i i think there's like actual pr firms
who do these like they specialize in
super random [ __ ]
we gotta find them i want one of those
though i want i need a trailer like that
trailer for the show they're just teddy
fresh or something
yeah for the show just promote
this is [ __ ] nuts it's got nothing
it's like a normal game
so wait let me see the uh
oh it's just a castle defense game
well that's probably an element of it
and you see there's like characters yeah
it's like kind of rpg-ish holy you got
[ __ ] in the game that's nuts no i'm sure
you do [ __ ] the game all right cool
i'm in
nice i'm sure you do
people like i'm not a fan of the game
but i love the music okay interesting
okay
despite being a rather softly
pornographic like game it's pretty
interesting game that is a good
storyline and pretty cool royalty aspect
man none of these comments are real
you know what they say ladies want the
top one percent of men
written by cobra tate actually
it's weird
just like i said
bro this looks nothing like the ad
exactly where the [ __ ] that ad come from
well there you go man this is a good
find sam that is really really something
i'm playing it right now
are you yeah
okay
i got uh like otto matched with a prince
named ian which is pretty funny no
okay ian can you ask him thoughts
princess thoughts
thoughts i haven't got to that part yet
actually ian i do want your thoughts on
something what do you think of the new
uh
kendrick single
uh
i i thought it was cool i think the
video was really
the attention-grabbing pretty
interesting thought
he turned into kanye was that
interesting to you
yeah and other people
it was cool
it can't yeah yeah
i i don't know i
i thought the song was all right um
i didn't love this song i'll be on i
mean the snow the song was nice
sometimes it takes it's got to grow on
me a little bit the kendrick stuff
it wasn't bad by any means the music
video was really cool though it was nice
i think um these single this won't be on
his album no it never is the heart one
yeah and these ones are always very like
kind of he's showing off his ability you
know to wrap it's very wordy it's very
complex i guess yeah yeah but it's not
very
melodic i guess
so i don't think i'd really want to
listen to it like on a regular basis
because it's it's not like catchy
in my opinion at least for me but it's
cool i like it that's a good analysis
yeah i'm assuming the album will have
more kind of musical this is more like
an information thing
and in a technical
showcase i guess
and and for that it's impressive i liked
it but and what was going through your
mind when kant when his face turned into
kanye
um i was like yeah that's a guy
that's cool yeah no it was really cool
his he turned into like oj
and kanye
and even will smith i was like damn will
smith just gotten the [ __ ] now he's
already
getting his face changed
you know jesse smollette
i like legs and uh ass
that's a new sound bite that i'm sure
will haunt me later
legs and uh ass and uh ass apparently
the last verse um
is
told from the uh perspective of nipsy
hustle that's what his face is nipsy
hustle yeah nipsy kobe made an
appearance yeah
very interesting you liked it though
yeah no i liked it it's great i mean i'm
just happy to see him i can't wait for
the album
it's just hype to see him actually
putting out
putting out tracks
it's not just a game anymore clue the
podcast
oh [ __ ] who killed ethan
wait who's that in the top left
oh samantha bee's trying to kill me now
that's right i should be trying to kill
her no i shouldn't even joke about that
but she's the one to claim my [ __ ]
ryan kevin i can see boogie i can
definitely see
god he's been
somewhat supportive of uh i love wendy
williams i'm one of her biggest fan big
fan
but she is she is all about killing
people
if you think she they should suffer
death to all of them
chet hanks was trending over the weekend
our boys
went viral for saying he has nothing to
apologize
about the jamaican accent okay let's
hear him out are there any marginalized
communities you want to apologize to i
don't know maybe the pothole community
no
i don't feel like i've truly done
anything offensive so
you don't see it as cultural
appropriation you see it as like a
celebration of culture yeah what the
[ __ ] is that
why is that set so insane show time what
is this show
this is actually like a physical set i
think
yeah
chetana
going big
take a backseat tom cruise tom cruise
who chet it's chet season
that's a nice set what the hell
what is this zee wee
it's on uh showtime
she just interviews people or what
yeah
okay okay zewie i see you
pussyclat
what did she ask him do you have any one
thing to apologize for what
let me go back i want to apologize too i
don't know maybe the pot talk community
the what community
huh oh
she's talking about the uh doing the
whole jamaican accents thing but she
said to what community what did she say
i apologize too i don't know maybe the
pottawatt community patois oh pat patwa
what does that mean i've never heard
that word
that's the
uh what do you call it creole
language that they
oh okay
interesting so she's saying
do you want to apologize for the bigger
bigger pickup right
no
i don't feel like i've truly done
anything offensive so
you don't see it as cultural
appropriation you see it as like a
celebration of culture
and then it's like social justice
warriors can like go kick rocks yeah
yeah
well sad there buddy
yeah
no comment got it no i mean i i 100
agree social justice warriors can kick
rocks
[ __ ] them ross
fascinating conversation
they're killing it over there at show
time
i mean
it's supposed to i don't think you have
i get it it's supposed to be uh
it's awkward yes
but at the same time
actually
good opportunity for an interesting
conversation that didn't happen
[Laughter]
you know if you want the real scoop on
uh chat watch the only real news station
left channel 5 baby
andrew callahan
does he really need to apologize though
i may
just did an accent and he's really good
at it
you know does chet owe uh
the people an apology for the jamaican
accent
should we do a poll this chat
should we do a poll on this i'm
genuinely curious
i think the white boy summer thing went
pretty sideways i think we can all admit
that
it's not the best time to be celebrating
being a white being a white dude
that usually comes off bad
okay maybe z was great i just saw one
minute guys don't get mad see we is
amazing she's the greatest
oh she asks everyone to apologize okay
see she's the i'm sorry zoe
please guys
can we can we do a poll please dan
love ziwi
stanziwi
zewi forever
i [ __ ] love her so funny she asks
someone to apologize
every time
also third option i don't care someone
said no opinion
yeah i mean chat hanks could have even
been a candidate for murdering me i mean
he sent me threatening dms and blocked
me
you know
me i don't have a plan
[Music]
just saying
does chad owe an apology
26
[Music]
say yes he does
[Music]
34 say no he doesn't
and 41 of people simply do not care
[Applause]
there you have heard it
you're already here folks
all right let's talk about amber turd
versus johnny dump
i feel like people have been milking
this thing i've barely talked about it
for the life of me i just can't really
pull myself to care that much about it
you know
shout out to emily baker friends of the
show her channel's been blowing up
because she's been doing have you seen
this dan
she's been doing lawyers react to the
whole
trial like four hour streams watching
the whole day
and here it is and she i mean that's
look at this a million views three days
ago
so good for her she's got expertise
on it but holy [ __ ] man good for her man
she's running this thing all the way to
valhalla look at this
holy [ __ ] dude
seven eight hundred nine hundred
thousand
but obviously she's qualified she's a
lawyer so i can understand people
wanting hear perspective but
people really been interested in this
johnny depp versus
johnny dump versus amber turd have any
of you guys been following this
no i've gone on my way not to to be
frank
out of just you have a principled uh
reason are you just not interested it's
not it's
i don't like
what a spectacle and what a like team
sport it's become i find it really
disturbing to be frank i think there's
just one team from what i can tell is
johnny depp
i've been watching asmr girl cover it in
death oh yeah and asthma goal is getting
like millions of views doing it too
right
yeah i've been watching a lot of the
trial lately just because of him so
everybody hates amber pretty much
unanimously is that right that seems to
be the
seems to be the way the the hive mind is
going right now yeah
yeah have you seen anything interesting
come out of this love that like is
surprising or is it all just everyone
hates amber turd i just kind of feel
like her lawyers are garbage and the
like professional witnesses that they
bring up is just making a spectacle of
themselves
uh i don't know i i kind of struggle to
deny
someone's allegations like that just
because of stuff like that so
i haven't
made my mind up yet but yeah that's
basically it
yeah
but i guess i should be paying closer
attention because we'd be getting lots
of views on this [ __ ] boy
you know what i'm saying
i see some people saying both terrible
i mean at the end of the day you're
talking about
a really toxic relationship that's just
all being aired out publicly that's
pretty nuts
that it's all being televised now i know
johnny depp was the one
allegedly who pushed hard for this whole
court case to be televised
his hope being of course that
he would win over the public and he has
i mean
basically
but little updates uh her imdb page is
officially amber turd ladies and
gentlemen
it's human fecal matter is it still say
amber turned oh it's been reverted yeah
it's gone so was that someone that
worked there did someone hack them just
to change that
uh do we have any intel on the amber
turd imdb page speculation it was a
hacker
yeah
there you have it
worth it
hack into the imdb database
just to change the name to amber third
matter
amber turd
actress and producer
you know aquaman
um
what else
johnny depp refers to taking amber poop
in the bed as a grumpy i found this odd
man i saw this clip
and i don't know why he has a heart such
a hard time saying poop i guess he's
trying to be respectful in court
but man just say it grumpy
downstairs
a wonderful point of just how funny it
was
that um
i thought that some
human being had actually
dropped a
grumpy
part in
[Music]
did they rehearse that they thought that
was funny
who calls it a grumpy
i've never heard a [ __ ] called a grumpy
i mean it was almost
i mean
you've been in lawsuits i know you've
done depositions but you never had to
like take the stand or anything like
that in a courtroom have you no no i've
never taken a stand in front of they
rehearse it um oh yeah and this is like
high level high paid yeah they do mock
yeah exactly right so you think grumpy
played well
i mean it went
that it depends on who you're playing to
i i suppose played well with the uh
have you ever heard that drop a grumpy
no i've never heard him my my shirts are
generally happy
i'm going in there after you i don't
know about that
but i'm not saying but my shits aren't
grumpy they're like they're fine
maybe some people a grumpy dumpy i guess
oh is that what it's from a grumpy dumpy
maybe
have you guys heard grumpy before i mean
what is going on here
well despite the fact it makes for a
killer sound bite and one that will live
on forever absolutely
by the way i also saw trending
that
people actually think amber heard did a
bump
during court can you pull that clip or
is it in here it's in there
which is nuts but okay let's keep
watching
on onto the bed
and they were
yakking they were yucking it up they
were laughing about the whole thing and
ah
yeah i think it's more a trial for the
public opinion he's put it on a show
for people at home in truth from what i
understand about defamation i don't
think he has any chance of actually
winning this
because the bar is so high
so he's just out here with zingers like
grumpy
that being said it does seem like she
[ __ ] the bed because she said it was the
dogs and he has two teacup yorkies that
weigh like five pounds and that [ __ ] was
was like the size of the whole dog's
body so
dropped a
grumpy
so obviously you know
that's pretty wild if she's [ __ ] in his
bed that's [ __ ] awesome to be honest
you ever been that mad before you just
[ __ ] in the bed well when we last talked
about this a couple weeks ago we all
said that nobody
here had had
a
revenge [ __ ] situation i gotta say i got
a lot of messages from people after the
show
saying somebody did it to them and even
a few people say that they've done that
so
so some so there's people in our
audience that have [ __ ] in someone's bed
in revenge yeah or maybe not necessarily
anybody like in their car or like i
don't know you know i don't know man
that's [ __ ] wild you just [ __ ] what
are you a [ __ ] gorilla i mean what
are you doing you're just going around
[ __ ]
that's so wild to me that you would just
go [ __ ] on something out of anger
like what is that
you're a human man
we are the apex we are the apex animal
and you're [ __ ] on things
god we have art and culture and language
and you are [ __ ] on things because
you're angry
get it together man
it was it was
you know it was a it was a tough couple
of days
and i really didn't
feel like
i deserved that
you know johnny nobody gets to deserve
to have their bed [ __ ] on
even the worst of us don't deserve that
so
that grump anyway grumpy so there you
have it
a pile of grumpy
hey shredder you need to make a grumpy
grumpy
grumpy
yeah so this was like really trendy
uh people thought amber took a bump of
coke
while on the stand
this has 220
000 likes
you're honestly if you think this you
might actually be you might believe
birds aren't real as well
who the [ __ ] taking a hit of cocaine
while on the stand
on a video
she's just wiping her nose man
right
i'm very glad that you're saying so
ethan this this was breaking my brain
it's so stupid what the [ __ ] do you guys
think she's doing she has a line of
cocaine and a tissue
you guys know it's like a fine powder
trained on her
and is
in a really high pressure situation
where there's she has plenty of other
opportunities to hit a bump if she
wanted to yeah
before or after her
taking the stand
also you guys know that cocaine is like
a fine powder you can't just be throwing
it around on a tissue and reliably take
a hit of it
y'all really trying way too hard with
this hating on amber turd ship
like come on now people really believe
this
evidently she's trying to get a bug out
she's trying to scoop a low-hanging book
she's using her nail to scoop her to get
a scooper grumpy out over there
grumpy yeah
see i think she was doing a blowout
no well that's more likely than cocaine
i mean yeah yeah i think she just put
the finger on she was blasting
oh she could have been blasting you're
right yeah
yeah she could have been doing a little
snot rocket which in itself is dangerous
in that setting you know because that
that could have gone disastrous could
have gone horrible well let's take a
closer look
yeah
definitely she took the the snot rocket
stance
she was ready to blow right bugs
but you all can't really be serious
right now with this [ __ ]
let me look at the quote tweets
oh careful
oh
this was not a covert snort to do this
in a courtroom you need an apparatus
called a bullet to store the material
and direct it up your nose
you cannot do a bump out of a tissue you
pull it out of your pocket jesus christ
people do some drugs
okay warrior
and i agree with you but jesus christ
it's a lot of intel
[Music]
booger blow pole is up
booger blow
66 boog
yeah it's still too many people voting
for blow i'm sorry speaking about blow i
really gotta pee again i chugged that
whole diet sodium
oh
my god
[Music]
people saying bad poll well i didn't you
can blame love for once love made this
one
what the [ __ ]
can you not wait who put up the pole
[Music]
sorry sorry for my reaction but no i
didn't oh who put up the pole then
one of the mods
wasn't me
i usually do
i can't tell if you're messing with me
i'm not messing with you it wasn't me
can we see that in the shot
i it just always comes from the podcast
so i don't know
can we mention uh what happened to love
on twitter
uh
yeah sure why not i guess love do you
want to
give it you want to have it right here
let's go with that love has been trying
for a long time
he's a tier three pokeman
uh sub
he's been trying to get that reply
and he hit her with the i wish american
electrical outlets looked like this
instead of this
it would make you way more happy when
you saw them and she said
agreed that's a [ __ ] simp
thank you thank you thank you
congratulations my friend
thank you guys thank you
thank you been waiting for that one for
a long time well quite frankly uh i
wasn't trying i mean i wasn't expecting
to get a reply ever so this is beyond my
greatest wishes so i want to thank
everyone for liking my reply for
retweeting and stuff that like that uh
and bringing bringing it to her
attention so thank you everyone yep
absolutely
happy for you man
thank you
uh
that's a [ __ ] simp
that's a sound bite love don't worry i'm
not i'm not coming for you
no i mean that's definitely simp
behavior yeah for sure i wouldn't blame
you
uh somebody just left a little comment
worked in the office there was poop on
the floor every other day in the women's
restroom
one time there was poop in both the
women's restrooms at the same time
that's uh
are you working what's going on
[Music]
yeah where's the cat were there any
couches in there i've been seeing a lot
of
women's room couches on the subreddit
evidently you were right all along cam
you should have you know
[Music]
maybe it wasn't my high school
maybe not somebody just donated 20
buckaroonies
and asked where these glasses are from
they came from the prop bin that we have
in the back i have no idea i've been in
there for
a long time
these glasses changed my life tattoos
that's right
it completely changed my
life uh ten dollars katie said i'm
willing to bet the tissue had something
in it
menthol or something to make her eyes
water that's why it seems like she's
sniffing rather than blowing i mean
that's still pretty conspiratorial but
that that is to me more believable than
that let's just all agree if she's not
doing cocaine isn't that really such a
delusional stretch though
that she would do that
in my opinion
maybe i don't know anybody here believe
that but what is this ball we're doing
now this is dan and love
oh who made the ball
somebody somebody uh uh
what do you call it put up a poll asking
if it was the bug or the uh blow and it
was not lover eye evidently so i assume
it's one of the
mods and now they're doing a little
trolling
oh the mods are out of control
well they're throwing up these poles
willy-nilly
i'm confused though
i trust you then but i know the mods
don't have that power i don't think they
should be able to do that
uh well it's probably that i meant
back here
no i think me dan trusts each other
it wasn't us there's a third someone
we've lost control of the show
we're hacked someone hacked the podcast
account to make that poll okay
everywhere
and all that's done is make relatively
uh enhancement holes hands up ends up in
there
all right if so if there's a mod that
can make a pole
or a hacker make a poll that says
dan
is a poo poo pee pee grumpy
yes or no yes honestly
his hands are up hands around love let
me see your hands
they're up
i'm not seeing anything guys i don't see
anything interesting well stranger was
one of you two guys
uh there's someone else in this room
that has the ability to throw up holes
and they've been awfully quiet
who has the ability to make bulge in
this room
ian thoughts
ian have you been doing this i'm i'm
switching um you do a lot of things
while you're switching
all right i think did you do the poll or
no answer
it was ian it was all right thank you
guys
okay there's no there's no ghost in the
system here grabber got that setup oh
gm i don't know about this
if you say no i'll trust you dude
really
yeah you trust me
you wouldn't lie
questionable decision
[Music]
oh yeah it's been too long
what's happening
[Music]
i pitched it down
bomber
uh there was also a great moment here
did we watch this like or not
this was a really
great moment as you can see
163 000 likes on reddit
on the facepalm subreddit this was a
very viral moment
where amber turd's
attorney
objects to his own question
and it's just confusion in the courtroom
after that
i think the judge even says
you that was your own question you can't
object to it uh here it is i'm sure
you've all seen this by now but very
good you didn't know what could cause
damage to mr depp's hand while you were
there on march 8th correct
dr kepler told me
he sustained an injury on one of his
faces rejection here's hearsay
you asked the question okay
i feel bad
where'd you find these guys
let's go
that's kind of a joke throughout the
whole trial he's been like objecting to
everything
and uh johnny that passed like every
when he says something he kind of pauses
and expects for him to interject
it's all hearsay
yeah old hearsay he's calling it it's
funny though
well in truth you guys
i think most people aren't used to
watching court cases but
i think the the truth is that
what his what her attorney's doing is
probably not that uncommon
and that's just kind of the way it is
but it looks absurd
when you're not used to seeing it let's
go
but he does seem like a discount
attorney doesn't he
he just seems so flustered here
you didn't know what could cause damage
to mr depp's hand while you were there
on march 8th correct dr kepler told me
he sustained an injury on one of his
faces rejection here's hearsay
[Laughter]
johnny's laughing
johnny's hooting it up like someone just
took a grumpy in his bed
oh
look at this okay he said sustained an
injury
definitely seems like johnny has way
better legal representation doesn't it
he is much richer than her let's be
honest or did she get a lot in the
divorce
what's amber turds she got a lot which
she promised to donate and that's
another like thing people are getting
mad at her about because she has only
donated a small percentage i know
someone else who did that
right i to be fair to her brian kavanagh
thank you for clarifying i i believe she
had said that she would donate that
amount over 10 years uh
not in one lump sum
according to this she's worth 2.5
million dollars which is obviously a lot
of money
but when you're fighting
a legal battle of this
uh
of this scale that's nothing yeah
so it doesn't surprise me that she's got
a much cheaper
lawyer because if you want to hire the
big boys the guys that are good
and it's not even about hiring good
lawyers the thing is you have to put in
you have to pay them the hourly rate to
put in the time to do the research right
they have paralegals they have huge
teams
reading everything going over evidence
preparing arguments counter arguments
and as dad said or i just called you dad
me
i meant to call you dan grumpy
[Laughter]
thought
it's a little weird
daddy
obviously they sound close yes we'll let
it slide it was a typo don't let it
happen again
anyway dad
and as dan said
they have to do even
full
mock
trials
and all the time spent prepping is
enormou
we're talking millions of dollars
probably yeah easily easily but johnny
depp is sitting on you know
75 million which honestly he might even
be worth
more than that that seems kind of low on
with his
yeah according to this he's worth 150.
according to this johnny depp's net
worth 150 million despite having
squandered
650 million dollars over 30 years 13
years
yeah i was gonna say i remember a while
back he's one of those guys huh
uh yeah i think i just found it there
was a whole rolling stone
article about him
um and i think he actually had a lot of
financial problems
that's incredible man yeah it's
estimated that depp has made 650 million
on films that netted 3.6 billion almost
all of it is gone now this article is
from 2018. dude
can you go down again
who the [ __ ] makes that
much money if he made six go down to the
numbers
16 50 million bucks off 3.6
billion
i mean he's making like
20 percent
of the gross one actor who makes that
much money that's insane
he's a big star 20 who gets bit what
worker in the world makes that kind of
[ __ ]
charlie charlie sheen used to make that
kind of money too charlie sheen doing
what uh two and a half men he got a he
got a pretty hefty pace two and a half
men yeah he got a pretty [ __ ] hefty
payday per episode
that was show even that popular at one
point it was yeah one of the biggest
yeah
also in europe it's very famous too yeah
two and a half men
also i have to imagine a lot of the
money that he made off the pirates
franchise uh probably came from
merchandising
um if he got some sort of deal where he
gets paid any time like his likeness is
used on like a toy or a shirt or
whatever and i mean you remember how
popular that was yeah yeah yeah for sure
totally
yeah that's probably where he made most
of his money is the pirates series yeah
merchandise
okay he squandered 650 million that that
that's wild
do you know how you know how bad you
have to be to what to lose that much
money
grumpy
and sometimes people are
not the best uh
not the best if you had 650 million
bucks you put in the stock market you'd
make on average 65 million dollars a
year
right in dividends just
free money
okay well anyway um
amber recently fired her crisis manager
uh heard parted ways
it's a firm run by barack obama no
uh excuse me
no i don't know former uh advisor for
two barack
obama what is happening
adviser to barack obama yes that i
believe during his first uh election got
it got it got it
i always find that a weird claim to fl
fame like i'm sure barack obama had like
a gajillion
quote-unquote advisors oh certainly yeah
um she fired them due to alleged
frustration over coverage that has
favored that
yeah well
she's asking for a miracle
grumpy you can't be grumpy you can't
you're gonna have to do better you know
you got this guy talking grumpy and all
this [ __ ] so that's a home run right
there oh yeah
people cheering for johnny depp as he
leaves court versus people booing
amber
i think most of the support for johnny
is honestly
has less to do with whatever they're
seeing in court
and i think people are just angry
because of the way she's dragged him
people love johnny depp right they love
his movies they love him
they don't want to believe he's a
terrible guy that's done all this and
she's been dragging him she ruined his
career
and i feel like this whole people have
been talking about justice for johnny
depp for years right
i've been seeing that around the
internet
so i feel like this whole thing's been
building up for a long time
on the witness stand and we have the
largest crowd show up to watch johnny
depp depart after court today here's
what the scene was like
[Applause]
[Music]
he's just an actor i mean what the [ __ ]
he's just an actor he just pretends to
do [ __ ] there was one clip i just can't
get over people idolizing actors
you know he's not really a pirate
there was one clip a
few weeks ago him rolling up to the
court he was listening to some [ __ ]
bob marley oh like exodus
movement of the people you kinda gotta
admit he's trying really hard of course
he's fighting for his life in the words
of r kelly
i'm fighting for my life here
but you know
he's just an actor guys
he pretended to be a pirate
and by the way he got paid like 600
million dollars to do it okay
it wasn't even out of the kindness of
his heart that he pretended to be a
[ __ ] pirate for you
he got paid more money than
all of you will ever see combined it's
fine good
now if you want to worship me
at least i'm actually here talking to
you
you know what i'm saying dan
what i do is way more
valuable than johnny dump
i'm talking i'm interacting you don't
know anything about johnny dump he goes
on stage he starts talking talking poops
grumpies and [ __ ]
i'm just saying you don't even know
anything about him
grumpy
right
i don't resp i actually
there's nothing wrong with actors but i
don't i don't get the fetishization of
uh
of uh actors
just saying
uh everybody's saying you're jealous
the johnny stands are coming for you man
i know you can't [ __ ] with johnny depp
these days people are so defensive of
poor johnny depp
he is a victim you guys are right if you
believe i don't know what to believe i'm
not he's a victim of abuse okay fine
you go out and [ __ ] cheer for him
because he's a victim of i'm just saying
i'm not even talking about johnny depp
i'm just talking about
actors in general people worship actors
yes he was abused his career was winning
i'm not talking about that you know
justice for johnny
johnny johnny [ __ ] yes papa
whatever i support johnny depp don't get
it twisted okay
just talking about actors
okay he was abused fine
you go out and cheer for abuse victims
is that what you do
and in the role of a lifetime and the
role of a lifetime
johnny depp as grumpy
the [ __ ]
don't you guys agree with me that
[ __ ]
actors are like over hyped
like i agree like
you don't know any you don't even know
if they're good people or not
their whole persona is
is is manufactured you don't know
anything about what they think what they
do in their private life they just
pretend to be people on screens and
that's cool and all
i just don't get the the fetishization
of actors it's just odd
like they're [ __ ] literally you don't
know anything about them
i'm an open book come worship me if you
like me you're right dan
uh i do way more what you see is what
you get with ethan yeah for sure
thank you
i'm just kidding about me but i'm just
saying that i have to say that for all
the [ __ ] haters are gonna make
compilations about like ethan thinks
he's a god
uh
but you know what i mean
like who's an actor that people really
worship
um keanu reeves
well okay keanu is [ __ ] awesome it's
different okay he's he's a great guy
actually people actually like keanu
because he is known to be a great guy
but he but he is a great guy dan you
people know that you don't know keanu
you don't know anything about it right
no he's a good guy no i love keanu
shut the [ __ ] up sorry
i honestly wasn't trying to undermine
your argument here and if anything that
was just the first one that came to mind
there those people worship keanu i'll
tell you what
[ __ ] abortion rights i'm going down if
anyone [ __ ] with keanu i'm going down
the courthouse and protesting all right
yeah i guess you're right i do love
keanu
[Laughter]
and people are throwing out some other
ones the rock uh the rock is a great
example you don't know anything
the rock you don't know anything about
that guy he is such a manufactured
[ __ ] star
shut up [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no you shut up [ __ ]
like the rock is one of these really
secretive ones where you don't know
anything about him
he just comes out all [ __ ] jacked and
does his thing
and he just sings about it's about drive
it's about power if you're poor it's
your fault
i added that
i mean keanu reeves people are starting
to open up that he's kind of a creep and
that's fine
i think jack black on the other hand
that's a thing yeah white oh
keanu reeves is a crap oh no i meant oh
no oh you are oh
hold on
[Music]
i meant leonardo dicaprio
how dare you mess that up
by the way when i say he's a creep he
dates young women i don't i don't know
that he's doing anything you know
illegal
like not in a creep like a brian singer
way you know just in a he likes young
girls way young models
i kind of feel like
age has a lot of things to do with how
much you like an actor because for
example when the pirates of the
caribbean came out i was like seven
years old and that [ __ ] got like
manipulated into my brain that i love
that dude interesting i kind of have
that weird feeling like i've almost
grown up with him that's super
parasocial feeling
they got you at that perfect age
yeah exactly so i'm wondering if there's
a lot of people in my age who kind of
feel the same thing that's interesting a
lot of these people look older though
like what the [ __ ] are you doing here
look at this guy he's like [ __ ] 50
60. what else does he have to do yeah
i don't know raise some kids [ __ ]
plan a funeral
i don't know
there's only one actor that i worship
that's that's worthy of worship
yeah who's that
michael [ __ ] ironside
the goat
all right there you heard it
from uh um total recall we love you
michael aren't you damn he got big
what's that one on the far left
what's up meyer
that's an iron side if you ask me
[Laughter]
a broadside
yo can you do me a favor and google
michael crow or russell crowe
before and after
i love russell crowe i used to love his
movies
gladiator one of my favorite movies
that's like what you said that hit me
right in the uh you're at the right age
right at the uh
what's the word why is my brain not
thinking today
i try to think but nothing happened
nostalgic it may write in the nostalgic
he was such a god bro
look at that tucked in [ __ ] bro this
guy's tucked the [ __ ] in this is for a
roll though
he was doing a roll what role is that he
was playing [ __ ] um
the [ __ ] i thought he was playing like
the fox news guy
yo
yeah you're right he's on set
but he's taken to it look at him bro
he's got a toothpick in
so wait what does he actually look like
when he's not all [ __ ]
damn he's [ __ ] he's massive he had a
good time preparing for that that's what
i'm saying
oh he looks great yeah
oh he's still a legend dude that's got
to be a fat suit come on
i don't know his face look at the balls
and pounds for the roll
dude i love that look at what he's got
like [ __ ] all over his shirt
wow i actually ate the onion on this one
[Laughter]
because he looks great he looks great
good for him
well that's that's just
you don't need to shame him for that for
christ's sake yeah
was he going off for a cigarette in that
the tuck photo oh yeah he's a smoker
that's what he's doing but i love that
he's got food stains on his shirt like
open that up again he literally has food
stains on his [ __ ] shirt that's
probably part of the scene
no i think he just had a rare steak
someone says it's a fat suit in the
title yeah it's not right here all right
well [ __ ] me i ate the onion all the way
i literally ate the onion so hard it's
convincing though
his face looks full that's what
got me well i think you know he's not
wouldn't it be cool if i was wearing a
fat suit and none of you guys knew
this whole time i could just take it off
you knew it was kind of like part of
your brand so you guys think it's a joke
he looks like gabe newell there with the
beard below the one you have selected
on the left
oh oh yeah
i see it
russell crowe for the
for the battle
jack black people the thing about jack
black is he puts himself out there way
more he tours
he does videos on youtube
you know much more about jack black as a
person
he makes videos with his son you know
he's a good guy
so don't ever [ __ ] say [ __ ] about
jack black i swear to god dude i love
him probably like one of the nicest
guests we've had on so nice like so
humble i got to [ __ ] because kyle
gasps brought his guitar
so i got to [ __ ] play master explorer
with tenacious d that was pretty [ __ ]
cool man that was quite a moment i
remember that after the show
that's cool dude
so let's see what else do we oh you know
uh we got what's in the title we got to
talk about uh avatar two we can talk
about right yeah avatars yeah i want to
talk about the frog army but we can hold
off i guess because we're already going
for what three hours
uh just under
all right you guys seen that [ __ ]
avatar i'm not an avatar lover
but you know what's weird i hate her to
be honest
i am a hater actually a little bit
but it was worried about avatars because
it was the highest grossing film for a
long time
and even though i didn't even really
like the movie i ended up seeing it
three [ __ ] times
[Laughter]
and you know there's this joke going on
like nobody even remembers avatar
uh it is still the highest grossing
movie of all time oh i thought it got
passed by it did it was passed uh by
avengers endgame but it has since
re-surpassed why
anniversary re-release and that counts
towards the total oh
[ __ ] here's the list
avatar's back baby 2.8 billion uh
endgame made two point uh just under 2.8
as well but 2.7
so like i get that avatar
looked awesome and people liked the
experience of watching it in 3d and
stuff
but
the movie was corny as hell and the
story was kind of dude wasn't it
i
am a
massive james cameron fan i was
unbelievably hyped for that movie
i went and saw it on
opening night at midnight and everything
oh you saw the midnight show midnight
showing
uh you know aliens is
still one of my favorite movies of all
time uh and i love the abyss i love
terminator
i love him as a director he made titanic
too right yeah he made titanic which i'm
less crazy i'm just saying he's like a
good movie
box office king
makes interesting movies interesting uh
uh you know blockbusters that are still
intelligent and have something
interesting to say
uh
i found avatar to be one of the most
disappointing movie experiences
i really did so you and i know a lot of
people still like it i went in there as
hyped as hype could be and i walked out
of that theater was like that was not
that great wait so you saw it at
midnight so you didn't get out of the
theater to like four in the morning yeah
yeah something like that yeah i saw it
another time like a week later at a more
reasonable time uh you still didn't like
it
uh
i mean it's not the worst movie ever
made but uh it's not that [ __ ] good
it might be the worst movie that james
cameron has ever made
how were the reviews even
because like
what are you rating it okay so 7.8 i
think that's warranted you know
it's like i that's kind of what i would
expect yeah i wouldn't say that it's
terrible but i and maybe it's my fault
for having such high expectations going
into it but i i really found the story
to be pretty lacking so did you do the
3d and all that yeah yeah i mean and
visually it was very impressive and you
know that was that was like the cutting
edge thing at the time i mean it started
that whole wave of 3d movie 3d was cool
they did a great job no i mean
from a technical perspective the movie
is is you know a masterpiece but um
you know
tired story uh you know very predictable
um and yeah i mean
i found the climax to be pretty
uninspired you know generic action scene
kind of stuff there really wasn't the
spectacle didn't do it for me as much as
i had hoped
and um i mean the only thing that really
lasting came out of avatar was basically
the fan fiction
i mean the only thing i see about it
today is like weird avatar creatures
getting it uh getting it on like dumbler
you know they make uh avatar fleshlights
too okay well of course they do do you
remember we looked at this a long time
ago
when we were talking about all the uh
worst tattoos of all time oh yeah the uh
dude that is like the full body avatar
guy yeah man
so sick
oh yeah
his body is a is a relic
he's the best
i love that he's just some [ __ ] dude
that drinks budweiser
and he loves avatar
people are asking for a poll i i guess a
poll of do you like avatar or not uh i
guess i don't think it's do you like
because i liked it fine it's the hype
that was weird it's like
do you love avatar should it be the
highest grossing film of all time that's
what i don't get yeah
and that's a 62 percent on on rotten
tomato which yeah that's kind of what i
yeah but i just don't get the growth the
highest grossing aspect the people just
losing their
damn mind over this and so when
avatar 2 comes out
the way of water
i just don't know who's really excited
for this i don't really give a [ __ ]
and again i'm being a hater ass
pessimistic [ __ ]
i get it
i'm very excited i actually okay i i
mentioned this theory to you earlier
ethan but uh i don't think the movie
exists
it has a release date
it's all a hoax it's a prank avatar 2
will not be coming out this year or any
year
i think that he's actually taken all the
money from the 12 years of production
that he's been working on embezzled it
and he's created some sort of underwater
city which he can lord over sort of like
you ever play bioshock yep yeah i think
he's like building rapture
uh somewhere well apparently there's
five avatar movies planned yeah
that's part of why i think it's it's
never coming out well it's going the way
star wars they're all gonna suck it's
gonna
i would say you ruined the franchise but
you can't i mean it's just one movie
that's not even that good so
write it all the way to the bank i guess
you know what's also crazy is disney
spent like a billion dollars
on
that avatar land
where in uh
disney world in florida yeah the florida
one oh for real there's an avatar land
like a billion dollars and it took
years to build and it's i mean it's sick
like don't get me wrong it's [ __ ]
sick and i'm hyped for the second one
but they make that [ __ ] back in like a
week oh yeah it's crazy avatar world
and disneyland
apparently it's really cool pandora okay
i'm actually interested what is this
let's see
interesting
yo the mech suit though that would be
fun
okay
interesting that's it huh okay i got i
gotta say that again you know i was nine
when that movie was released cool this
[ __ ] in my life
i ever
yeah i even had like yeah back then
definitely i haven't watched it once
everything did you fantasize about women
avatars sex
no no i don't think so no yes did you
ever want to uncoil your tail and
[ __ ]
get all mixed up in another tale
or whatever they did oh that yes
absolutely of course
yeah
yeah they even like had friends who had
like avatar birthday parties and [ __ ]
and it was [ __ ] wow okay
yeah so my fellow swimmers probably know
what i'm talking about that [ __ ] was
cool when when you were nine
so i don't know i mean it's just showing
like them swimming and flying i just i
don't know guys
i'm calling i think this movie's gonna
[ __ ] suck
and not like the first one which was
like good but overblown i mean like suck
suck like jar jar like this whole
trailer was giving me jar jar binks
vibes
well a lot of people love those movies
too so you know
nobody dare you might not
yeah uh zach unironically thinks the
phantom menace is better than the
original star wars films that's
that's not what i said look at this we
were just talking about the other day
this is not good
this is like cats vibes
oh no i don't do them like that look at
this [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
weird somebody said avatar and final
fantasy vii made me an environmentalist
okay well fair enough okay then i get
the message save the earth i get the
message it's not the worst message for
sure i i do appreciate that the you know
colonial power in the film is the bad
guy and they come to realize that and
they
kick them off i i get it i get i get the
undertones of everything i just thought
the execution was a little
predictable a little
uh overdone as a story trope i mean
obviously not in a sci-fi setting like
that but i just want to see sigourney
weaver with her cgi cigarettes again
oh she had cgi sigis
well this december
should we take oh should we vote on the
on the imdb score like we did with sonic
we all got blown out with sonic man that
movie ended up being decent yeah yeah
and that was on the original trailer
though to be fair enough you you keep
doing this to yourself whenever you like
have a heavy-handed uh
film take you always end up
later being like i was wrong i really
liked that if you said it sucked like
which one i never you were really
excited for matrix
[ __ ] that movie sucks so bad you thought
sonic was gonna be the worst movie ever
i never saw sonic but okay okay well it
did i did it was it was decent it was
definitely not the worst movie ever made
but yeah i think we literally said
that and
oh my god
i couldn't even finish it man
i think it'll just be like
i i'll be surprised if it has the same
kind of
blockbuster
oh right you can pointed out you were
talking a lot of [ __ ] about the justice
league movie at this time
and then you kind of liked it exactly so
yeah yeah i know
but you know you admit when you're wrong
so that's
it's all right to make a prediction
mega awesome nerds says let's freaking
go
sonic is the new king of cinematic
universe move over marvel
yeah that might be true he said he saw
sonic 2 like eight times or something
when we were hanging out with him at
zach's show the other day i forgot the
exact count but it was a lot
actually went and saw it with him the
first time oh well there you go yeah we
had another mod say guys please don't
say your age in chat that's a good
advice
or just anywhere on the internet there
are creeps online who may target you
you're right
uh you're right don't don't don't write
that you're like [ __ ] 15 or something
in your address
yeah i i even keemstar might be watching
yeah probably
what's that love
well i don't know if it's like super
necessary but i i i tend to remove like
people asking what's the age of the h3
uh like community on reddit and stuff
because there's creeps out there who
look at that [ __ ] and follow up probably
yeah why even ask that it's all look
yeah it's obvious that most people who
watch the show are probably
at i think most people watch the show
are over 20
definitely
the met the biggest majority is probably
18 to 35
but uh
you know
if you're under 18 don't [ __ ] say
that to people who are asking your age
yeah
jesus
okay well there it is the avatar you
know i don't know i wish i could watch
the trailer but i know these [ __ ] are
gonna claim me which is such [ __ ]
i'm trying to [ __ ] promote your
stupid-ass movie
you know we're gonna have a million
people watch this podcast and you want
to claim my whole [ __ ] show for
watching your trailer [ __ ] you
it's so annoying let me watch your
trailer it's just so [ __ ] up yeah
grumpy
i am grumpy
i'm about to take a grumpy by the way no
matter how much people sim
bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do you mean like
the cgi looks bad i just don't know why
their eyes are so far apart you just
blow just in the fantasy man i'm not
into it but okay i'm being an [ __ ]
we're gonna we're gonna all gonna see it
i'll watch it yeah we'll give it a fair
chance
i don't know why there's no way it's
gonna live up to the best avatar though
oh the only avatar i care about i love
on
i love
what's her name
no no it sounds like you don't love her
no she's talking about katara that was
her name katara yeah this character no
no not her the other avatar
oh oh oh you're talking about korra
yeah the follow-up [ __ ] man whatever how
i'm begging for a new avatar what's
going on dude i think that they're
trying to make a live-action tv show no
no no no no no no they're making another
the creators were involved with the live
action at first on netflix but then they
dropped out and now they're making
another cartoon up now okay they're
making a cartoon the creators are the
original people are yeah yeah uh the two
guys i forget their names but um they
were i think the netflix live action
ones gotta suck because they dropped out
due to creative oh
you cannot make live action from
animation period ever
it's always bad
when has it ever not been bad
i'm trying
yeah i'm trying to think of an example
of remember when they made death note
live action like what the [ __ ] was that
live action animated decisions usually
not so good there's got to be at least
one that was decent
cora was awesome someone said chorus
trash shut up dude corey was awesome
i love cora i don't know why people
complain about cora that show [ __ ]
rules the animation was overheated too
so
sick in that show the animation is very
good
uh the story was great
i thought they were both great
i don't know why everybody's hating on
korra that's [ __ ] i think a lot of
people i don't know
i think a lot of people got tripped up
by the uh
the second season which i do kind of
agree was a low point
um it gets better after that though like
i think a lot of people probably got to
that and like the show sucks and dropped
out
um
but yeah ultimately it was a worthy
successor to the original dude one of
the seasons was like one of the greatest
ever with
the one bender who could fly are you
talking about henry rowland's character
oh was that henry i mean that that whole
art that whole story was yeah [ __ ] that
was sick that was a good one for sure it
was so sick who could you hate that show
yeah if you haven't seen the avatars
they're both awesome i don't i don't
stand cora
slander in this house
[Laughter]
so you say they are making a new cartoon
cam yep uh in 2021 they made avatar
studios so they are uh that's exciting
do you know who they're working who
they're working for funding with
nickelodeon for paramount plus so oh so
nickelodeon came crawling back yep
paramount plus i guess i'm buying
another [ __ ] streaming [ __ ]
paramount plus can you all just work
together and make like just i've got an
idea how about everybody gets a channel
and then i sign up for one thing and pay
monthly and you all get your channel and
we call it cable or satellite and you
just pay one place and then they all
come together and have their own channel
and i can like open a guide and flip up
and down on the channels and then have
it all in one place what do you guys
think oh wow that's a novel concept
i love it
pretty cool idea huh pretty novel
pretty interesting i'm just gonna pirate
it all
i mean paramount plus you guys are
really testing me with that [ __ ] you
know i've i've signed up for peacock now
peacock plus
obsessed with housewives
dude you got to get that because it got
the office on there that's the only
place to watch it oh they moved it to
peacock yeah yeah they knew what they
had there
and parks and rec
did i have so many streaming services
it's insane
i've got disney apple hbo netflix hulu
amazon peacock
and now i've got about to hit paramount
plus
whatever the [ __ ] else is on that [ __ ]
i probably have more that i can't even
think of showtime
i've been seeing a lot of people throw
out
uh animated uh series
that were adapted to live action that
they thought was decent the only one
that i've seen that i like kind of agree
with
is the scooby-doo movies
yes
those were those were pretty good that's
a pretty high bar
if that's the best you got i mean there
was a lot of others being thrown out
people said
the ghost in the shell adaptation i
honestly
i never watched that i was too afraid to
i really like ghost in the show and it
it just seemed like it was going to be a
disaster but if you liked it fair enough
i don't know if i mean what's going on
was the one where they had scarlett
johansson as the japanese character so
good stuff there
uh ninja turtles oh the live action
ninja turtles do slap that's true
that's basically [ __ ] weird though at
the same time
i love those movies when i was a kid
though
so much
all right guys we have we talked about
everything in the title we have we have
we have we have we hit it all and we've
been going for three hours seven minutes
so if i die in a mysterious way just
know it was covertate or brendan schwab
or
uh
or or one of the other twins
or the birds are
the birds are
no don't don't do them like i'm no not
him but i'm just saying the people who
are the government agents who are oh
trying to cover it up covering this up
would be interesting responsible
interesting very interesting all right
so what do we got planned this week
uh
well we
have um a very interesting caller uh i
think that we're gonna have on wednesday
but i don't i don't i want to keep that
as a surprise can you discord me
sure
we plan all this stuff but i don't know
the
oh interesting yeah
so that one totally confirmed
um
wait the lawyer are boy the lawyers
calling well and i wasn't gonna say uh
we're going to try on good lawyer
asap
yeah love that [ __ ] let's go let's go
um
and then we have another episode of
leftovers of course um no guest up this
friday uh though we do have some
exciting ones coming up
uh in the near future do you want to
talk about the one that uh
that we were just booking last week
want to reveal that wait wait wait what
the guess that we're having on in the
near future here
oh
sure you can say it i mean it's in the
works it's in the works it's not we
don't have a date locked yet but we're
trying to get chelsea manning on the
show
i just think she has an incredible story
yeah
and ethan's been uh
talking to her so we're working on that
and i just wanna right yeah i just i
wanna do more interviews and i just
wanna find people that have like
specifically really interesting stories
like though you know the birds aren't
real guy he's got a this incredible
story
it's so easy to have a conversation and
it's just can be so interesting
no offense to like youtubers and stuff
because they are they're you know
they're great
but once you talk to
a couple of them it just tends to be the
same topics over and over
which is i think why stop doing so many
interviews because you want to talk to
all your friends
and it's a good way to get new people
watching but sure at the end of the day
it just gets really repetitive and
nothing again paused on it too when we
were doing them all via zoom because of
the pandemic and it was just not that
yeah i mean i'm okay with zoom
interviews but
in general like the one we had today was
great yeah
but you know it's like you have
the same it's like so you know what
what's you
what's it like being on youtube [ __ ]
youtube right man it's uh you know it's
like i don't know
so i'm i do want to start doing more
interviews though
for sure
yeah chelsea
has an incredible story talk about
kendrick what can i say i love it i'm
waiting for it
i mean comedians are great guests too
just because they're
you know they're entertainers speaking
of uh comedians uh next week we are
going out for the uh redemption arc
of uh mr jimmy lee
oh
bingo
bingo work with me
he's texting me about ten times
confirming we need to i think do we need
to vet some of his new material before
we send him out in the world again we
we've been doing that i think we need to
continue to do that he's got to practice
on us and you know i i'm dan reminded me
that
this is our thing this time yeah this is
our shoot no damn it no [ __ ] no like
yeah zach was stressing hard and i was
like listen you're not
you're the driver you're in the driver's
seat this time last time he was this
time he's your protege exactly so so
he's got to just be
new jimmy
you know he's got a
new guy new jokes fresh material but
still a little backbone and little
you know character of jimmy lee but no
you know nothing racist or
homophobic
that arab joke was a banger though
yeah
yeah
but um oh abey's not here so it feels
weird to say that but right yeah you
know i don't have my you don't have the
seal of approval walk that back
new new jimmy new jimmy next week next
tuesday we're going to uh
okay so much to look forward to guys
all right well i actually have a picture
of jimmy uh trying not to tell a racist
joke
jimmy trying not to call a girl ugly or
fat
challenge impossible difficulty audio
audio
audio audio audio audio audio
i think the art do we do can we get
someone to check the audio please
audio audio
leo can we get the audio please
all right well y'all
what do you want me to say about ozark
he already said buddy oh i was waiting
for everyone to catch up on it
are you guys gonna be mad if i spoil
ozark
i don't even care about it bro i forgot
about that show it sucked
i hated the ending it was so lame
all right you know it's the end of the
show so if you care about ozark spoilers
just stop watching
bye-bye turn it off bye-bye like the
evolution of the characters
made no [ __ ] sense all of a sudden
the kid the son who hates
that
mom who's a [ __ ] psycho [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] evil character
and then everybody's all of a sudden
rooting for her at the end
and the son is like sniping the private
invest did you watch it dan i'm talking
no and i who's watching the show who am
i even talking to
uh
everybody in the background watch it
right sam
yeah ian and sam watch it like the son
hated
the mom and then all of a sudden he's
ready to kill the private investigator
at the end
like the whole last season was basically
just about how
the wife's evolution into becoming like
an absolutely irredeemable character who
wins for some reason for no reason at
all
at the end of that show
and i feel like they copped out a little
bit just trying to be like well this is
how the great families are made and so
that's what the show's about we decided
which i don't think was the plan from
the beginning at all
i didn't like the ending it was a
cop-out man i thought yeah i don't know
i don't think that any of the birds uh
deserve to get out of that alive
personally
no and they tried to make it a point
about like and then why they even
crashed the car they crashed the car
nothing happens what the [ __ ] is
happening like they're crashing cars
they're shooting private investigators
like this whole show is just off the
rails i'm sorry
it was totally off the rails
i'm reading comments
uh
you know
yeah wendy the the mom was just and then
ruth died but frankly it had like no
[ __ ] impact by the time she died
what they the family never really gave a
[ __ ] about her anyway so the climax is
supposed to be that ruth died and by the
time she died i really didn't even give
a [ __ ]
i wanted to see the bird's reaction
like we don't even know if they knew
like we have no idea
even like found out she was killed
and let's be honest
marty already threatened to [ __ ] turn
her into them to the mafia like there's
about
it's not even that big of a
of a crisis for them like you got to
choose ruth or you got to choose
everything you've been building it's
like
they [ __ ] sell ruth out in a second
man
and then the whole thing was unresolved
with the mom
why was the hitman at ruth's trailer
they never explained that
i assumed wendy told her where root that
it was ruth but no she didn't she didn't
tell her are you talking about uh nelson
that's the hit man that worked for the
mafia
yeah ruth's friend killed him yeah yeah
yeah no yeah i don't know why i don't
remember didn't explain that why was he
at her trailer there was i there was a
totally unresolved plot there where i
thought wendy told her that it was ruth
that killed the guy
and that was going to be a whole
interesting conflict there where you're
going to have
wendy versus marty
which is what the whole [ __ ] show was
building towards where these two
characters were growing apart and they
had to decide when their interests were
so misaligned what was going to happen
between them
and they [ __ ]
never went to the place that the show
needed to go man
they just never went there it i don't
know
you know i don't know what do you guys
think
i just see i'm fully in support of you
i just see people spamming love and
white face
uh i saw a lot of people agreeing
earlier that uh
it's uh
the ending was not great
but i honestly have no idea what you're
talking about so it's hard for me to uh
you know who they should have got was
claire
the farm the claire shaw the
pharmaceutical girl
she like owned the
the company was that the girl who came
back because i totally forgot who that
character was
uh no
no who the [ __ ] was she who came back to
help ruth i was like who even are you i
forgot yeah
yeah ian and i were like
and she sniped and she like killed that
[ __ ] hitman with like no hesitation i
was like okay murderer
i think she was fine
it's weird man i don't know
can you read super chats what do you
want me to say
i agree with ethan
the ending was terrible but the shooting
the private investigator was like it
made sense
maybe because if you look at the
beginning of the show the sun was like
he was torturing animals he was like a
serial killer then he became totally
normal and then at the end he became
like [ __ ] killing people again i
don't know
somebody uh said wendy died in the car
crash and the ending is what she's
dreaming of
that makes more sense
i said when they caught when they
crashed the car i said
i said ela if they all die in a car
crash i mean basically it's like just
saying the whole show was a dream why
not just wake up in a [ __ ] hospital
bed and
nothing ever happened
do we know if the creators were tied to
a new project so they wrapped up the
season sloppily like what happened to
game of thrones
and so maybe
you need to give wentworth a try
okay
check that out jd wentworth
i don't need cash now
i need cash now
eight seven seven cash now
all right i gotta go then we're going on
like 10 hours now we're just reading god
cold for cash
last uh thing i wanted to state because
people were asking
when is olivia coming back the answer
[Music]
is may
23rd that's not next monday that's the
following monday two months from now
uh olivia will make her triumphant
return to the h3 podcast so for all you
olivia simps out there
good news
all right guys have a good week we'll
see you on wednesday
bob's your uncle yadda yadda
see you on wednesday
[Music]
grumpy
you